ses nombreux travaux que ce soit à
travers le déclin de la compétitivité de
la ferme France ou bien par le prisme
encore trop tabou du suicide en
agriculture que nos rapporteurs
Françoise ferra et Henry Cabanel
avveaient très justement qualifié de
DRAM silencieux les mots de notre
agriculture sont très nombreux manque de
reconnaissance voir agribaching voire
même action violente contre les
agriculteurs comme nous l'avons vu
récemment à sain Soline problématique du
revenu qui ne concerne certes pas tous
les agriculteurs mais une part non
négligeable la question des retraites
agricoles trop faible alors même qu'une
loi votée à l'unanimité censé permettre
un calcul sur les 25 meilleures années
n'est appelé à entrer en vigueur qu'en
2026 fléo des normes et des
surtranspositions
franco-françaises qui minent notre
compétitivité et pass nos agriculteurs
en situation de concurrence déloyale
avec nos partenaires les plus proches
accord de libre échange qui trop souvent
ne rechigne pas à sacrifier
l'agriculture européenne encore
considéré comme secteur non stratégique
enfin ambiguité française intenable sur
le Green Deal européen et sa déclinaison
agricole assurance d'une mort lente de
notre modèle agricole et de ce qu'il
reste de notre souveraineté alimentaire
face à cette sédimentation et c'est un
mot que vous employez très souvent
monsieur le Président de problématique
il est peu de dire que le gouvernement a
forte affaire le Premier ministre a
tenté vendredi dernier de séduire les
agriculteur promettant de mettre
l'agriculture au-dessus de tout très
franchement nous n'aurions pas pu mieux
dire en tout cas sur le diagnostic qui a
été dressé en revanche nous aurions
certainement pu mieux faire et la
déception et il faut bien le dire à la
hauteur de la force de de ces mots mots
m TS quelques mesures de bon sens certes
sur le GNR ou encore sur les E mais où
est la vision 10 mesures
technico-administratives et puis s'en va
ou du moins essai puisque les
agriculteurs n'ont pas été dupes et que
la mobilisation se poursuit plus que
jamais et pas plus tard qu'hier lors de
sa déclaration de politique générale le
Premier ministre a annoncé vouloir une
ex tion agricole française encore une
fois on ne peut que saluer l'ambition
tout en restant dubitatif sur les
traductions concrètes qu'emporteront
toutes ces déclarations d'amour à notre
agriculture au sein de notre commission
nous l'avons déjà dit et je rends
hommage au travail de la précédente
présidente Sophie prima puisque bon
nombre de ces travaux que j'ai cité ont
été faits sous sa présidence si le
Gouvernement entend travailler
sérieusement au redressement de la ferme
France une proposition de loi
transpartisane voté ici au Sénat est
toujours sur la table puisqu'elle n'a
pas été inscrite à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale elle ne règle
peut-être pas tous les problèmes mais je
pense qu'il s'agit là d'une base de
travail solide fruit d'une concertation
avec le monde agricole je m'arrête là
bien évidemment pour vous céder la
parole monsieur le Président pour que
vous nous indiquiez comment vous
accueillez les quelques annonces
quelques annonces du gouvernement et
quelle suite vous entendez donner à
votre mobilisation qui Chac le sa aura
bien une fin mais sur laquelle
aujourd'hui vous êtes particulièrement
déterminé je vous laisse la parole je
précise que l'audition est captée et
diffusé en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et la vidéo sera ensuite
disponible en vidéo à la demande et je
demande bien sûr à nos collègues qui ne
vont pas manquer de vous poser de
nombreuses questions d'être très concis
et d'éviter les questions redondantes
merci monsieur le Président je vous
laisse la parole très
volontiers merci beaucoup madame la
présidente et bonjour à tous merci de
l'accueil qui m'est réservé ici dans
votre commission à votre invitation pour
parler à la fois de l'agriculture
j'avais déjà eu la chance d'être invité
devant vous il y a maintenant quelques
mois avec un diagnostic qui me
semble-t-il nit pas très loin de de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui et puis donc
évidemment l'idée de de vous décrire ce
qui se passe je voudrais peut-être
commencer par parler de la vision parce
que je pense que c'est ça qui est le
plus
intéressant la vision elle est assez
simple on est dans dans dans le pays qui
est reconnu comme étant celui qui a une
des agricultures les plus durables au
monde ça veut pas dire que par ailleurs
on n pas des progrès qui doivent
continuer à être réalisés mais enfin
faisons le constat que quand on regarde
ce qui se passe ailleurs dans tous les
autres pays de la planète on est
finalement avec capacité de production
dans des conditions économiques
environnementales et sociales qui sont
reconnus comme étant les plus élevés de
la planète premier élément
ensuite on a clairement un monde dans
lequel on est dans un milieu ouvert donc
on a des échanges on a qui sont par
ailleurs nécessaires mais j'aurais
peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir si
certains d'entre vous ont des questions
et des questionnements forts d'un
secteur agricole qui est aujourd'hui un
secteur d'ajustement je crois qu'il faut
être capable de de le dire avec
aujourd'hui moins de 400000
exploitations agricoles professionnelles
c'est 100000 de moins qu' a en 2010 et
sur ces 400000 exploitations 100000 font
moins de 20 25000 € de production brute
standard dit autrement elle ne
permettent pas aux agriculteurs qui qui
sont inscrits dans cette catégorie de
pouvoir en vivre ce sont ça peut-être
des doubles actifs ça peut-être des gens
qui font autre chose on sait que
sociologiquement on aura près de la
moitié de la population agricole à
renouveler en tous les cas la moitié
d'entre elles partira en retraite dans
les 10 à 12 ans et c'est en tous les cas
166000 exploitants dans les 5 à 7 ans
c'est ce sont les chiffres officiels
voilà un peu le le décor le tout dans un
contexte
où évidemment les sujets de
compétitivité de défis climatique de
sujet de décarbonation sont autant de
challenge à relever qui pour
l'agriculteur évidemment sont des soucis
quotidiens un agriculteur on a
l'habitude de le dire à la FNSEA c'est
d'abord un entrepreneur quelle que soit
la taille de son exploitation quel que
soit son son territoire quel que soit
son type de production et donc par
définition il a besoin à la fin de
l'année que son entreprise comme toutes
les entreprises que ce soit un
commerçant ou un artisan dégage du
revenu pour permettre de continuer à
rembourser les investissements à pouvoir
préparer les projets à pouvoir manœuvrer
évidemment à vivre et le constat
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a des écarts de
plus de plus en plus
importants en agriculture enfin le cadre
donc la mission reste la même produire
pour nourrir c'est c'est ça je crois qui
est attendu on peut avoir des
contributions annexes celle de produire
de l'énergie renouvelable demain on sait
qu'on aura dans le cadre de la
planification écologique des sujets de
bouclage de biomasse sur lequel
l'agriculture est attendue et pour
lequel aujourd'hui on a un certain
nombre de réponses qui ne sont pas qui
ne sont pas là c'est pas de la mauvaise
volonté c'est que on sait pas boucler la
totalité des chaînes c'est en tout les
cas ce qu'on travaille avec le
secrétariat général à la planification
écologique et puis au dehors donc de de
cet apport de volet énergétique donc je
parle pense à la biomasse ce qu'on peut
faire avec le photovoltaïque sur les
toits notamment nos élevages mais demain
l'agrivoltaïsme puisque il y a un projet
qui est sur la table la
méthanisation peut-être d'autres
solutions demain on a on aura en tous
les cas un élément de réponse au mix
énergétique puis enfin ce qu'on appelle
le volet des aminités positives comment
demain on pourra être rémunéré pour
notre contribution à la décarbonation il
existe d'ors et déjà des propositions
elles sont à ce stade euh pas très
développé mais enfin ça existe et
aujourd'hui un agriculteur qui est
capable de prouver que son sol va
stocker plus de carbone peut en avoir un
produit euh et on peut imaginer demain
que d'autres paiements pour services
environnementaux soient aussi un un
complément de revenu donc produire pour
nourrir évidemment pour le faire j'ai
dit qu'il fallait du revenu et puis il
faut aussi des conditions de production
et je voudrais en dire un mot ça
m'amènera à ce qu le cadre d'abord dans
un cadre européen puisque vous le savez
l'essentiel des politiques publiques
conduite sur le sujet agricole sont des
politiques européennes alors en premier
le déquel la politique agricole commune
mais mais ça n'est pas la seule
politique qui vient sur le champ
agricole avec des sujets évidemment de
de de de contexte européen de plus en
plus de de surtransposition et en tous
les cas de subsidiarité qui conduisent
bien souvent à la surtransposition pas
de manière
systématique un volet national et puis
ensuite des conditions d'échange donc là
je veux faire évidemment mention euh
des accords internationaux alors là
aussi je voudrais être clair la France
agricole ne peut pas se passer de
continuer à échanger qui imagine demain
la viticulture concentrée sur le marché
national c'est sa fin programmée et
immédiate qui imagine que sur le champ
des céréales à un moment où on est dans
une bataille géopolitique avec notamment
la Russie et l'Ukraine sur le continent
africain on puisse passer de la
production et puis je pourrais vous
parler des produits laitiers transformés
et d'un certain nombre d'autres produits
par ailleurs comme toujours on peut
avoir des intérêts offensifs et
défensifs et c'est vrai que sur les
intérêts qu'on souhaite protéger on a
notamment la question de l'élevage je
faudrais en dire un mot parce que c'est
évidemment
central notamment dans les sujets de
planification écologique tout le monde
nous dit que la prairie est quelque
chose d'essentiel puisque sur le plan de
la biodiversité sur le plan du carbone
c'est un levier important mais que par
ailleurs on constate tous les jours que
conserver notamment des bovins que ce
soit en lait ou en viande c'est
compliqué pour les éleveurs je le dis il
a quand même un moment où on pourra pas
avoir des prairies d'un côté et rien à
mettre dessus ça n' pas la prairie a une
fonctionnalité c'est de nourrir un
troupeau voilà et donc du coup il y a
tout un tas de de sujets qui qui qui se
posent sur cette question là un moment
où où ça décapitalise beaucoup voilà
donc ces conditions d'échange qui
prévoit qu'on puisse importer notamment
de la viande bovine mais je pourrais
vous parler des ovins dans des
conditions de réciprocité qui questionne
le monde agricole interroge je le dis
c'est pour ça que j'essaie de rester
équilibré devant vous en disant on peut
avoir des intérêts offensifs et il y en
a dans d'autres secteurs mais ce qu'on
constate c'est que souvent dans les
accords commerciaux la question agricole
vis-à-vis des pays avec lequel on on
veut passer des accords la question de
l'agriculture est souvent une monnaie
d'échange l'Europe est plutôt
exportatrice de biens et services de
produits manufacturés et et les produits
qui veulent signer avec nous les pays
qui veulent signer avec nous des accords
ont plutôt de de des produits agricoles
ou tous les cas du secteur primaire
amener donc il faut qu'on on le regarde
et c'est là où on dit que on a un sujet
de de règle et de norme alors je lis
beaucoup de choses en ce moment y
compris beaucoup d'excès nous n'avons
jamais dit que il fallait pas de norme
la norme elle est même capable parfois
de nous protéger donc j'évite les excès
mais je dis que malgré tout il y a un
certain nombre de choses qui ne sont pas
comprises et qui se traduisent par de la
surtransposition ou des choses qui qui
n'ont pas je vous prends un exemple
parce que après tout il faut quand même
être un peu concret aujourd'hui et c'est
des remontter parce qu'en ce moment tout
remonte là mais voilà en production
ovine quand vous avez deux moutons qui
sont dans la même stabulation donc il
peuvent se toucher ça pose pas de
problème mais si si vous une fois par
vous tondez votre mouton la laine qui en
ce moment est un marché très déprimé qui
trouve peu de débouché que vous voulez
la garder la broyer et la mettre au sol
pour faire une litière bien c'est
interdit parce que la laine c'est un
déchet aujourd'hui au sens de la la
réglementation voilà bon cet exemple est
un parmi d'autres mais voilà
l'agriculteur euh voyez c'est des choses
qu'il a du mal à comprendre pour des
raisons sanitaires essentiellement
concernant la liine bon je pourrais
multiplier les exemples je voulais vous
dire pourquoi à un moment on ça
questionne alors je le dis tout ça est
une question vous avez bien fait madame
la président de le préciser de
sédimentation c'est-à-dire que ce qui se
passe en ce moment et le cumule de
règles de normes com qu'au début vous
acceptez de de de voilà vous ça ça Râ un
peu mais bon et puis un moment quand
quand vous êtes arrivé dans le trop
plein et
bien ça déborde et et c'est le moment
dans lequel on est et et je le dis pour
l'ensemble de mes collègues agriculteurs
qui sont en ce moment sur un certain
nombre de de points en France l'attente
est énorme l'attente est énorme et
peut-être même au-delà de ce que on
imagine avec évidemment des sujets très
nationaux donc ça voilà mais beaucoup de
sujets européens et et je le je l'ai dit
depuis quelques jours en responsab ité
sujets européens ce ne sont pas des
sujets qui se règlent en 3
jours sur voilà donc je j'essaie
d'appeler au calme et à la
raison on aura aussi je veux le dire
devant cette assemblée parce que c'est
votre rôle un certain nombre de sujets
d'ordre législatif à pouvoir faire
évoluer et notamment dans le cadre de la
ploa la fameuse projet de loi et
d'orientation agricole dont on rabat les
hilles des agriculteurs
depuis de long mois oui vous nous avez
promis le passage
devant les assemblées avant enfin au
début 2023 puis après l'été puis à la
fin de l'année puis au début de l'année
puis là le Premier ministre nous a
indiqué qu'il souhaitait prendre
quelques semaines supplémentaires pour
pouvoir compléter le texte ce qui est
plutôt une une bonne nouvelle alors nous
on voudrait vous dire ce qu'on veut y
voir bon évidemment ce qu'il y a
aujourd'hui avec les éléments
d'installation et de transmission qui
est important comment on transmet les
entreprises et aujourd'hui l'entreprise
agricole ne se transmet pas dans les
mêmes conditions qu'une industrie qu'une
entreprise prise industrielle et
commerciale donc ça c'est important
comment on fait pour à la fois attirer
des jeunes les aider à se lancer dans le
métier et faire en sorte que ceux qui
quitte le métier puisse le faire dans
des conditions dans lesquelles ils ont
intérêt à le faire et pas de dire je
reste agriculteur jusqu'à 70 75 ans avec
tous les sujets de pénibilité donc il
faut pouvoir accompagner ça on aura tout
un volet autour de la compétitivité
alors je je le dis parce que je sais que
cette maison a travaillé il y a quelques
mois dans une proposition de loi
transpartisane à des sujets de
compétitivité alors est-ce que c'est
ceela est-ce qu'on en ajoute d'autres
voilà je je je je laisse les
parlementaires faire leur travail mais
en tous les cas on a ces sujets très
clairement parce que dans le moment dans
lequel on est on a aussi un sujet de
compétitivité faut accepter de le dire
voilà et puis enfin ce qui est essentiel
pour nous c'est d'y voir des sujets
autour de la souveraineté alimentaire au
premier rang desquels la reconnaissance
que l'agriculture est d'intérêt général
majeur voilà donc après je ne suis pas
juriste des gens sont bien plus
compétent que moi pour pour traiter de
ces sujets mais l'esprit en tous les cas
c'est ça et faire en sorte que quand on
prend des décisions on puisse au moins
euh regarder ce qui est l'impact donc
nous on est très demandeur d'études
d'impact je le dis parce que notamment
on pourra peut-être parler du Green Deal
on a eu un certain nombre de de sujets
sur le Green Deal et et et les études
d'impact qui aujourd'hui montrent que
finalement le Green Deal est un échec il
est un échec pour les associations
environnementales hein il est un échec
pour pour la production et quand vous
voyez qu'au terme des 5 ans de ce mandat
à peu près toute l'Europe agricole et
dehors je suis pas persuadé que voilà
alors c'est pas que le Green Deal il y a
aussi des appareils sujets de
fonctionnement on a eu un
commissaire européen à l'Agriculture qui
de mon point de vue n'était pas à la
hauteur de de la tâche qui était la
sienne qui n'a pas permis de mettre
cette dynamique et d'essayer de trouver
ce qui mon point de vue et son rôle
espèce de ligne de crête qui permet
aussi de de trouver des consensus en
Europe voilà donc donc ce sujetah il est
posé sur la table nous serons en
élection au
mois de juin et et les Européens se se
définiront je veux dire aussi que dans
le moment dans lequel on est à la FNSEA
on a veillé à rester dans le cadre
professionnel je le dis parce que les
récupérations
politiques ne sont pas notre créneau à
la fnsoa on a des gens qui viennent de
la gauche du centre de la droite et et
maintenant un peu plus de l'extrême
droite voilà non mais je j'ai pas de
problème avec ça et et la fnso ne prend
pas de position politique je le dis et
on a veillé à ce que il y ait pas de de
récupération à aucun moment en tous les
cas moi j'ai été très clair sur ce sujet
mais j'observe que il y avait la volonté
de de faire ça et je dis aussi que dans
les statuts de la fnsoir si on s'engage
dans un mandat politique en tous les cas
national ou régional on peut pas garder
ses responsabilités voilà donc dans le
moment dans lequel on
est on a eu d'abord une première phase
qui a consist à être invité comme
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux à
rencontrer le Premier ministre que nous
avons fait lundi il y a une semaine
voilà donc avec un échange qui
consistait à à poser le diagnostic moi
j'étais très intéressé de savoir si nous
partagions le diagnostic c'est important
de savoir si avant de démarrer à
travailler ensemble on est déjà au clair
sur ce que sont les éléments de force et
de faiblesse parce que je voudrais quand
même rappeler dans le moment dans lequel
on est que l'agriculture a des éléments
de force et que s'il y a des menaces il
y a aussi des opportunité voilà j'essaie
de regarder aussi comment demain on peut
continuer à à avancer donc on a posé le
diagnostic avec le Premier ministre et
puis on en est resté là bon je reviens
pas sur ce qui s'est passé vendredi le
Premier ministre qui est descendu en
ocitan qui a fait une belle opération de
communication qui s'est finalement
traduit par une forme
de
suragacement et puis qui nous a conduit
dans dans la la la la situation la
situation dans laquelle on on est euh
je dis aussi que beaucoup de gens en ce
moment critiquent la
FNSA je pense que le gouvernement est
bien content de nous trouver en ce
moment pour savoir avec qui négocier je
le dis aussi très clairement parce que
il y a d'abord pas que la fnsoa d'autres
syndicats
enfin chacun sera libre de porter ses
revendications j'ai compris que le
premier ministre recevrait les autres
syndicats en tous les cas pour ce qui
nous concerne après avoir fait des
remontées du terrain on a aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de propositions qui ont
été adressées au Premier ministre et sur
lequel on travaille donc on a eu des
séances de travail voilà donc le premier
ministre souhaite aller le plus vite
possible nous ce qui nous intéresse
c'est qu'on puisse prendre point par
point alors évidemment en étant là aussi
rigoureux entre ce qui est
franco-français sur lequel il a la main
ce qui est franco-français sur lequel on
a besoin du législateur donc je sépare
bien ce qui relève du décret de ce qui
relève de de la loi et puis ensuite on a
des sujets européens euh voilà qui ne se
règleront pas en quelques jours même si
le président de la République lui-même
est à Bruxelles aujourd'hui et demain et
puis enfin on aura un rendez-vous
électoral européen dans lequel j'imagine
que d'ici cette échéance chacun portera
les visions et et les agriculteurs se
définiront voilà peut-être ce que je
voulais vous dire en propos introductif
et je réponds bienment à vos questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président de
ces premiers propos donc vous imaginez
bien que les questions sont extrêmement
nombreuse donc je vais encore vous
rappeler soyez concis précis évitez de
trop poser le débat aller directement à
la question à l'essentiel et bien sûr si
la question a déjà été posée
abstenez-vous de la poser ou trouvez
trouvez vite une autre alors on va
prendre les questions de Franck
Menonville de Frédéric Buval et de Henri
Cabanel oui merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président de tout
d'abord vous dire que sur le le terrain
il faut vraiment souligner à la fois la
force de la mobilisation mais aussi
l'esprit de responsabilité des des
agriculteur les manifestations et les
mobilisations se font dans dans le calme
avec une force de de conviction mais
avec une un vrai esprit de de voilà de
de de de citoyenneté de responsabilité
je crois que vous en êtes d'ailleurs
aussi l'artisan moi je voudrais
peut-être vous dire
vous vous avez évoqué donc ce que vous
souhaitez
voir être positionné dans la dans la loi
d'orientation agricole on voit bien que
la la difficulté de de de cette crise
c'est qu'elle vient de loin vous parliez
de de sédimentation
elle touche à des facettes européennes
elle touche à des à une érosion de la
compétitivité de l'agriculture française
liée à une superposition de de politique
publique on peut vraiment aller aussi
euh remettre sur les 20 années passées
lois sur l'eau Grenelle de
l'environnement et autres où on a
demandé finalement à l'agriculture très
souvent de de répondre à des attentes
environnementales et sociétales et on
sait pas en même temps euh euh on n pas
armé puisque le président de la
République aime bien ce terme réarmer
n'est-ce pas euh la la compétitivité de
l'agriculture donc ma question elle est
simple qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez pour
voir lever cette cette crise et C barage
en action et en proposition immédiate
pour répondre il faut le dire davantage
à du à du conjoncturel et qu'est-ce que
vous souhaitez
voir engagé par le gouvernement et par
l'Europe sur des des mesures plus
structurelles pour
restaurer la compétitivité et la place
de notre agriculture merci Fran Frédéric
Buval merci madame la présidente
monsieur le
Président je vous ai écouté
attentivement et je je souhaite vous
assurer qu'en Martinique certainement
plus qu'ailleurs l'autonomie ou la
souveraineté alimentaire est un vrai
projet de société pour favoriser la
production locale et permettre à la
population de se nourrir convenablement
en quantité et en qualité en 2020 il y
avait 2680 exploitation agricole à la
Martinique soit une baisse de 19 % par
rapport à
2010 les exploitants agricoles ne
demande qu'à être plus accompagné pour
produire plus et aussi répondre à une
demande locale envahie par des produits
d' rotation de dégagements qui sont
devenus de et qui sont souvent de
mauvaise
qualité aussi tris trois pistes de
réflexion sur les problématiques de
l'riculturere mè que je souhaite
soumettre à votre réflexion monsieur le
Président la première concerne les
spécificités du foncier de l'accès à la
terre entre les conflits d'usage les
contraintes environnementales
climatiques ou juridiques du fait de la
division nos exploitations sont plus
petites plus enclavé et donc souffre
d'un sous-financement chronique
pénalisant la rentabilité économique du
secteur et donc à terme la création et
la transmission des exploitations la
seconde piste de réflexion se porte sur
les leviers de production et de
commercialisation adapté aux autres Maes
pour cela je prends un exemple simple
comment aider les Maes de Martinique qui
sont de bonne volonté mais qui ne
parviennent pas en dépit de la loi
égalime à proposer dans leur cantine des
goyaves ou autres fruits locales plutôt
que des pommes même si les pommes sont
très bonnes de que les pommes en effet
les productions locales partissent des
coups d'entrant de production
bien plus élevé que de l'exagone
[Musique]
oh coup d' de production bien plus
élevés que deagone en raison deement
géographique C cous affectent l'ensemble
de la filière et limite les débouchés
commerciaux alors dans le
prolongementction sur le de mer c'est
tout un plan
d'accompagnement que nous proposons pour
les fili et local la trè pistte sur
l'adaptation financement des chambres
consulaires cette ces entités sont
souvent les RAR interlocuteurs pour
l'accompagnement technique et
administratif des expoitant en effet
comment accepter quel que soit le
montant réel des pertes subies lors de
catastroph naturell à mariniique tous
les exploitants reçoivent la même somme
forfaitaire aussi ma question est simple
monsieur le Président comment votre
syndicat entend porter les porter les
besoins urgents de simplification et
d'accompagnement attendu par les
agriculturs en trom
Cabanel merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président comme l'a évoqué
la présidente dans ses propos
liminminire nous avons été à l'origine
d'un rapport sur le mal-être des
agriculteurs en
2021 je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails mais tout ce que vous
revendiquez aujourd'hui et tout ce que
les agriculteurs revendiquent
aujourd'hui sur le revenu sur
l'agribaching sur la
simplification avait été bien spécifié
mais je veux juste revenir sur la
première des propositions
qui est été donc de faire de l'avenir de
l'agriculture une cause nationale
aujourd'hui le Président le premier
ministre a dit qu'il fallait placer
l'agriculture audessus de tout pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas pris cette proposition
pour vous et de nous aider aussi à à la
mettre en place dès 2020 dès
2021 deuxè question ne croyez-vous pas
qu'il est temps que les filières est une
véritable stratégie à la fois nationale
et et territoriale et et je vais vous
prendre un exemple sur une filière que
je connais bien la viticulture je l'ai
déjà dit ici mais je vous le dis à vous
euh comment peut-on à la fois demander
donc des primes à la plantation euh
comment peut-on à la fois demander des
primes à l'arrachage comment peut-on
demander l'accès à l'eau et et et
croyez-moi je pense que dans un
département comme le mien et dans
d'autres aussi l'érau il faut de l'eau
mais pourquoi pourquoi faire parce que
en même temps demande donc des primes
pour la cilation donc je pense qu'il
faut qu'à un moment donné ça soit clair
dans la stratégie et et et trème et
dernière question qui était éminemment
importante et notamment par rapport au
projet de loi d'orientation agricole sur
le foncier aujourd'hui 2/3 du fronciers
disponible va à l'agrandissement des
exploitations et aujourd'hui quand on
sait que 50 % des installations se font
hors cadre familial on a besoin de
fonciers comment pouvons-nous inverser
donc la tendance sachant que au niveau
des Saffire c'est quand même une mission
de service public et la première d'entre
ell c'est l'installation donc des jeunes
voilà monsieur le Président je vous
propose de répondre à ces trois
premières questions même si dans une
question il y en avait beaucoup
d'autres merci madame la Présidente je
vais commencer par répondre à la
question du du sénateur Menonville bon
sur les les discussions qui sont
actuellement sur le sur la table bon il
y a des discussions qui sont
franco-françaises sur tout ce qui
concerne alors je vais prendre dans
l'ordre donc on pourra y revenir les
sujets donc ayant trait au au carburant
à l'énergie au GNR C annoncé il y a des
sujets et entrai au coupt du travail
notamment à la reconnaissance de des
sujets autour de te que qui un sujet que
vous vous connaissez bien les sujets
autour des des filières je pense
notamment à un grand plan autour de la
viande bovine qui est un un sujet de
préoccupation au moment où enfin je dis
viand bovine et d'ailleurs au moment où
on a une décapitalisation du cheptel
importante en France et et que je relie
avec la question des prairies que j'ai
souligné tout à l'heure on a des sujets
évidemment de de VTI j'y reviendrai tous
les sujets de surtransposition autour
des des phytosanitaires donc on pourra
parler du conseil stratégique on pourra
parler des des sujets de séparation des
sujets de d'instruments de mesure enfin
tout un tas de de sujets qui qui qui
questionne les agriculteurs la question
de l'eau évidemment qui sera aussi un
sujet central j'ai discuté récemment
avec un certain nombre de présidents de
conseil départementaux je pense
notamment à la présidente du conseil
départemental de lariège qui me disait
qu'elle souhaitait pouvoir mettre en
œuvre un certain nombre de d'outils de
stockage d'eau avec de la maîtrise
d'ouvrage et qu'aujourd'hui la loi ne le
lui permet pas voilà donc c'est des
sujets typiquement sur lequel il faut
qu'on puisse revenir pour permettre que
encore une fois avec des modèles qui
peuvent être très différents parce que
celui de la riège n'est pas la même
chose que ce qu'on vit dans le
poidoucharante par exemple enfin en tous
les cas nouvellequitaine n'est pas de la
même n'est pas du même tonneau et puis
ensuite des sujets européens dans les
sujets européens j'ai j'ai parlé de la
PAC mais il y a des sujets autour de la
directive industrielle qu'on appelle IED
dont une partie concerne
l'agriculture il y a d'autres sujets que
l'agriculture dans IED mais enfin il y a
un volet agricole et et le trilogue qui
a abouti il y a quelques semaines
conduit à ce que si on ne change rien en
2028 un élevage de 21500 poules
pondeuses puisse être sur le même Parché
de compétition que son homologue
ukrainienne qui a 1 million de volaill
et qui rentre aujourd'hui en franchise
de droit de douane voilà je je pose ça
je prends forcément le cadre un peu un
peu élargi mais je je veux que vous
compreniez ça et puis après on a les
sujets évidemment d'accords commerciaux
alors je dis pas que tous les accords
commerciaux sont remettent en cause mais
enfin il faut quand même qu'on regarde
les contenus celui qui déferait la
chronique en ce moment c'est plutôt le
le cur dont on sait que ce qui gêne
dedans c'est les 99000 tonnes de viande
bovine supplémentaire qui r je dis
supplémentaire parce qu'il en rend déjà
près de 300000 tonnes donc voilà je et
le sujet c'est pas d'importer de la
viande bovine là aussi je voudrais qu'on
soit précis je lis beaucoup de de de
contevérité le sujet c'est comment c'est
produit voilà on a du mal à comprendre
qu'un élevage moyen français de viande
bovine qui est d'environ 80 vaches alors
plus la suite hein les gunis c'est voilà
soit comparé à un fidelot sargentin ou
brésilien je vous invite à aller voir un
jour si vous êtes dans ces pays c'est
entre 3000 et 5000 animaux
c'est c'est voilà c'est c'est c'est des
sujets de décarbonation importé pas
systématiquement mais ça mais ça
peut-être voilà donc c'est ça qui a qui
a derrière par ailleurs on peut aussi
avoir des intérêts offensifs sur le
Mercosur je je ne le N pas j'aiessayer
de le dire tout à l'heure voilà donc et
puis enfin dans les sujets du moment il
y a la question ukrainienne alors là
aussi je vrais être très clair parce que
bon l'Ukraine est en guerre l'Europe
doit apporter son concours à un peuple
qui se bat pour sa liberté ses
frontières son modèle très bien bon donc
il y a pas de malentendu mais l'Ukraine
est un grand pays agricole c'est à peu
près un/4 de l'Europe agricole dans le
moment dans lequel on est qu'on vienne
en aide aux ukrainien je pense que tout
le monde peut le comprendre mais ça
n'empêche pas de poser la question
agricole je vous donne quelqu quelques
exemples il est rentré il rentrait
d'habitude avant le conflit 20000 tonnes
de sucre ukrainien en Europe il en est
rentré l'année dernière près de 700000
tonnes je pense que tout le monde
comprend qu'à un moment en terme de
déstabilisation des marchés il y a un
problème bon qu'est-ce qu'on dit nous on
dit que il faut qu'on trouve à partir de
de clause de sauvegarde la possibilité
de faire rentrer quelques volumes parce
que après en franchisee de droit de
Douine parce qu'après tout c'est pas
c'est pas choquant qu'on qu' Contin
commercé mais que le reste on regarde
comment éventuellement on peut faire des
corridors pour réexporter parce qu'on
comprend bien que les ports de la mer
Noire sont pas aussi disponibles mais ce
sujet il faut l'adresser et si vous
posez la question un agriculteur
polonais ou roumain il sera encore plus
déterminé que ce que je viens de de vous
dire donc le sujet c'est pas de tomber
dans les agriculteurs ne pensent qu'à
eux veulent pas se soucier de l'Ukraine
il y a une réalité de de marché voilà
donc il faut quand même qu'on la regarde
parce que ça se traduit derrière par des
fermetures de de de d'outils sur tout le
territoire national voilà quand vous
avez une sucrerie et que vous êtes face
à ce sujet de compétition c'est c'est un
problème et et on pourrait le le
multiplier donc voilà ce sujet c'est pas
pour dire encore une fois l'Europe est
une île on veut rien faire mais on a
besoin de de le regarder et puis ensuite
il y a tout ce qui est sujet
simplification parce que là on peut en
faire alors il y en a plutôt une bonne
nouvelle annoncée par le Premier
ministre que de dire on se met autour de
la table tout le monde est invité dans
les préfectures et puis on on liste et
puis après on agglomère et on regarde ce
qui est rap faisable moi j'ai envie de
faire cet exercice il a jamais été fait
après est-ce que il donnera du fruit ou
pas je je veux pas voilà notre rôle
c'est de se mettre au boulot du type de
ce que je viens de vous éclairer
typiquement sur le GNR l'annonce qui a
été fait sur le pied de facture nous
paraît aller dans le bon sens voilà
parce que tout ce qui permet un
agriculteur de passer un peu plus de
temps à son à son activité principale et
un peu moins à remplir des papiers va
dans le bon sens voilà donc ça on a
envie j'ai listé les mesures de manière
rapide he mais voilà et puis après je le
redis il y a tous les sujets législatifs
donc installation transmission
compétitivité souveraineté
alimentaire je je je continue madame la
Présidente alors sur la question de du
sénateur du Val de la Martinique bon
d'abord on noublie pas l'agriculture
ultramarine je le dis aussi parce que
j'ai eu nos collègues de la Réunion il y
a quelques jours qui après le cyclone
était quand même dans des conditions
difficiles alors vous parliez je vais
essayer d'être concret sur a ation du
financement des chambres et des aides
voilà bah là on est typiquement dans le
cadre européen puis qu'en fait le
dispositif des minimis qui permet
d'apporter du soutien se fait dans un
contexte européen pour pas que ce soit
distorsif et le déminimis aujourd'hui
est plafonné pour l'agriculture je dis
bien pour l'agriculture à 20000 € donc
aujourd'hui si on peut pas aller au-delà
des 20000 € monsieur le sénateur c'est
parce que le cadre européen ne le permet
pas voilà donc après je dis pas qu'il
faut pas un plafond mais là aussi on
demande à ce que ce plafond puisse être
augmenté il a été dans d'autres secteurs
d'activité donc c'est c'est c'est c'est
possible voilà mais l'explication très
concrète des raisons pour lesquelles à
un moment on peut pas aller au-delà de
20000 € alors qu'il y aurait des besoins
bien supérieurs c'est celui-là euh bon
sur les sujets production et de
commercialisation avec les importations
y compris de produits voilà bon le cœur
du sujet pour nous avant la
commercialisation c'est la production ce
que nous disent les producteurs
martiniicaais je vais prendre l'exemple
de la banane que vous connaissez bien
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ils ont un certain
nombre de contrainte de production
notamment parce qu'ils ont des maladies
parasitaires du bananier et que sur la
circosporiose noire notamment ils ont
des problèmes de de production donc il
faut qu'on arrive à regarder comment on
peut continuer à avoir un appareil
productif qui nourrit et puis ensuite
vous posiez la question du du déboucher
je je rappelle que dans le cadre de la
loi aujourd'hui on est censé dans les
cantines de Martinique mais mais comme
de de métropole d'avoir
50 % de production donc de qualité ou 20
% de bio ou signe de qualité et qu'on
sait aujourd'hui que les objectifs fixés
par le gouvernement à son propre à sa
propre administration ne sont pas
remplis voilà je je dis ça quand même
c'est dire que moi je veux bien prendre
un certain nombre de responsabilité à
regarder ce qu'on peut faire mais il
faut aussi que tout le monde respecte le
cadre d'engagement donc le ministre de
l'Agriculture lui-même a dit qu'il
allait veiller à ce queon puisse monter
en charge je sais aussi et peut-être les
élus ici le savent mais il y a aussi un
sujet quand même d'accès que quand vous
augmentez le prix de la cantine dans une
école c'est c'est un sujet de de
discussion or voilà il faut qu'on
accepte de discuter de ces sujets moi je
dirais que le prix de la cantine pas
trop mon mon sujet mais comme il se
trouve que je suis local j'entends aussi
ce que ce que les gens disent il faut
accepter que dans un certain nombre de
cas ça puisse valoir un peu plus cher
pas beaucoup plus cher un peu plus cher
et que on peut aussi avoir des produits
importés à bas cout mais qui ne
remplissent pases ses objectifs sur le
foncier bon c'est pas qu'un sujet
ultramarin si je puis dire parce il y
avait aussi la question posé par le
sénateur Cabanel mais sur le foncier
dans le cadre des discussions avec
l'État et ça me fera peut-être une
transition il y a aujourd'hui ce qu'on
appelle un sdrea un schéma directeur
d'attribution des terres disponibles
avec le l'installation en premier
critère voilà après on est dans un cadre
alors parce que vous parliez des
saffaires mais il y a pas que les
saffaires il peut aussi se faire des
affaires de gré à gré la s'affaire n'est
pas n'est pas systématiquement présente
il faut d'abord que comme dans o les
transactions il faut que le vendeur et
l'acheteur se mettent d'accord
accessoirement et ensuite il y a des
critérisations donc c'est installation
ensuite c'est confortation et ensuite
c'est agrandissement c'est comme ça que
c'est prévu dans les schémas
départementaux après il s'applique ou il
s'applique pas il peut y avoir quelques
non mais
je voilà moi je constate comme vous que
parfois il peut y avoir des des des des
sujets ça a été aussi renforcé dans le
cadre de la loi sans
passous qui prévoyait qu'on puisse aussi
contrôler les transmissions de part
enfin les transmissions
partielles de part sociale bon le sujet
de fond c'est l'accès des terres c'est
aussi le modèle derrière ou les modèles
que que que ça développe et et nous ce à
quoi on tient c'est vraiment la
possibilité pour l'agriculteur quelle
que soit encore une fois la production
le revenu et le territoire que il en
vivent c'est c'est ça qui qui compte
pour nous donc on a aussi des endroits
aujourd'hui où où le foncier trouve
difficilement
preneur voilà il y a aussi des sujet
dans certaines régions très spécifiques
de de des prises
agricoles voilà donc je regarde ça aussi
avec beaucoup de de de de recul parce
que quand vous avez comme dans votre
région des endroits où il a plus moins
de 100 mm ou 120 mm en une année sur la
question de la production ça pose quand
même des questions et que ce soit la
viille même un olivier a besoin d'un peu
d'eau voilà donc je sais qu'on travaille
sur est-ce qu'on peut mettre demain des
amendiers de la viille voilà mais il y a
aussi ce ce sujet donc derrière le
foncier il y a aussi la capacité du
foncier à dégager du du revenu
euh sur sur la filière
viticole bon on est très conscient de ce
qui se passe hein c'estdire que à la
fois vous l'avez dit en 3 ans deux
campagnes de distillation qui ont
atteint des des des des des sommets et
pas seulement de de vin on va dire
standard mais y compris le vin en AOC je
je pense à Bordeaux qui la dernière fois
a mis des quantités très importantes à
des tarifs je crois que c'était 75 €
lecto en aossé on peut pas dire que ce
soit rémunérateur et pourtant des
volumes ét là très important
eu en ce moment le sujet c'est pas
tellement les aides à la plantation en
ce moment le vrai sujet c'est les aides
à l'arrachage et avec un débat y compris
à l'intérieur de la profession en nétant
pas viticulteur je je prends la distance
nécessaire mais entre arrachage
temporaire et arrachage définitif chacun
expliquant qu'il faut le plus
d'arrachage possible mais plutôt dans
les appellations des autres enfin je je
le fais euh
un un peu rapide mais vous me
pardonnerez mais enfin il y a aussi un
peu ça bon aujourd'hui le sujet c'est
quel marché quelle segmentation et
quelle r commerciale parce qu'on aussi
beaucoup de vins qui arrivent d'Espagne
dans des conditions d'importation et de
la francisation qui parfois questionne
bon donc là ce travail il doit être fait
rapidement parce que la situation n
n'est pas tenable et d'ailleurs dans
dans les actions qui ont été faites
depuis quelques jours là où c'était le
plus qu où la colère était la plus
grande c'était souvent dans les zones
viticoles avec une tradition viticole
que vous connaissez probablement mieux
que moi et qu'on a vu ressurgir je pense
à des actes qu'on ne peut pas accepter
voilà donc en tous les cas pour ce qui
est de la FNSEA et de son
volet et de son action autour des sujets
de viticulture on est on est très au
clair sur la nécessité de de de regarder
la segmentation des progrès avait été
enregistré il faut aussi donner acte de
ce qui a été fait depuis 20 ans
notamment dans le langdoc après la
viticulture elle est plurielle parce
qu'on parle beaucoup du langdog de
Bordeaux mais les sujets sont pas les
mêmes si vous êtes en Champagne en
Bourgogne donc il faut aussi regarder ça
avec voilà je le dis aussi on avait des
des secteurs qui marchaient très fort je
pense notamment au cognac et qui
connaissent depuis quelques mois un un
frein important notamment parce que
l'exportation et notamment sur le
continent américain était très largement
voilà et comme toujours quand vous avez
des marchés qui sont qui poussent
beaucoup vous pouvez prendre quelques
mauvaises habitudes et quand le marché
se resserre de manière assez brusque
être en difficulté je le dis aussi parce
que dans les primes à la
plantation le gros de la troupe
concernait cognac voilà près de 3000
hectares par an et donc je pense aussi
que là tout le monde va prendre
conscience qu'il faut être un peu
raisonnable
pardon Oui Oui mais ou aussi depuis 10
ans on implante
énormément énormément de de vignes et
évidemment le marché est en ce qu'il est
quand ça tire tout le monde en veut et
puis quand ça freine on sait plus quoi
faire des vignes donc il faut qu'on
trouve aussi les bons réglages
voilà alors rapidement si c'est possible
reméy Cardon Patrick Chauvet et Daniel
salmand merci madame la Présidente si je
j'en crois les chiffres du ministère de
de l'agriculture vous le savez mieux que
moi 25 % des agriculteurs dépassent des
revenus agricoles de plus de 100000 par
an et 25 autres en dessous de 30000 par
an bref certains gagnent de mieux en
mieux leur vie quand d'autres ont de
plus en plus de mal à boucler les fins
de mois alors monsieur le Président de
la FNSA puisque vous prétendez défendre
et je vous pense sincère là-dessus
défendre le revenu des agriculteur coûte
que coûte que pensez-vous de plafonner
les marges de la grande
distribution pourquoi vous ne le
revendiquez pas alors que nous savons
très bien c'est demandé et attendu par
la profession merci Patrick
Chauvet Patrick Patrick Patrick pardon
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président merci de de votre Présence JE
SUIS sénateur de de Normandie
avec les mêmes questions qu'ailleurs je
crois et et je reviendrai sur un volet
qu' me semble un peu oublié dans dans
les revendications que je partage et ce
qu'on entend finalement c'est ça c'est
ça s'est construit sur sans doute 20 20
20 à 30 ans je voudrais savoir quel est
comment vous vous voyez les choses par
rapport au ministère de l'Agriculture
moi j'ai le sentiment que on a des
ministres compétent de très bonne
volonté et ça aurait pas de sens que de
taper sur les hommes ou les femmes qui
qui prennent ces responsabilités là mais
que le ministère n'a plus de poids
parfois l'impression que le ministre se
bat d'abord en interne avec d'autres
ministères se bat avec les agences au
pluriel avec la Cour des comptes
rappelez-vous qui dit qu'il y a trop de
vache mais qu'oublie dire que si on
diminue les vaches faudra les acheter
les produits ailleurs ou alors faudra
intensifier la production à l'unité de
des vaches laitières enfin on entend
plein de contradiction et du coup ça
matche déjà à l'intérieur de la tête du
de de ce pays donc on entend
peu aujourd'hui au travers toutes ces
revendications là comment on peut
repositionner un vrai ministère de
l'Agriculture qui puisse agir au lieu
d'essayer d'être tout le temps pris dans
les contradictions les contradictions
inter ternes moi je je voudrais aussi
souligner les les dégâts qui ont été
faits en communication tout à l'heure
mon collègue a évoqué l'agribaching moi
j'avais été à l'époque je suis dit mais
qui a pu inventer cette chose
aujourd'hui on entend que les Français
soutiennent leur agriculture c'est assez
logique c'est l'agriculture qui qui qui
les nourrit mais rappelez-vous de
l'agribaching la traduction d'abord on a
le droit de parler français c'est c'est
tapé fort l'agri bashing on peut socio
professionnellement faire du bashing sur
tout on l'a vu sur les forces de l'ordre
on l'a vu sur d'autres catégories socio
professionnel mais les dégâts que ça a
fait che chez les agriculteurs c'est
c'est c'est terrible le ressenti d'être
comme ça le Bou émissaire d'une société
je je crois qu'il faut faire attention
et qu'on prête pas assez attention
surtout aujourd'hui au moment où on en
est au côté humain aux femmes et aux
hommes qui travaillent en agriculture
moi j'entends beaucoup les éleveurs on
perd des éleveurs en Normandie vous
imaginez l'image de sans nostalgie d'un
temps révolu de la Normandie on perd les
éleveurs laitiers tous les jours en en
Normandie mais il y a un peu tout ça il
y a l'aspect des filières vous vous en
occupez très bien il y a l'aspect des
réglementations et ça sera la fin de mon
propos euh mais qu'on remette l'humain
au centre de nos décisions au centre de
la table sinon ça tiendra pas euh tout
ne tient où que ce soit que s'il y a des
hommes et des femmes qui peuvent agir et
et essayer qu'il puissent agir en en
sérénité vous avez évoquer sur vous
alliez vous mettre au travail sur
essayer de la simplification je pense
que la pire des choses ce serait de de
créer un ministère de la simplification
parce qu'on aurait tout le contraire de
de ce qu'on souhaiterait je suis pas sûr
et j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les
préfets que ce soit là que ça se passe
euh je n'ai pas personnellement la
méthode mais je crois qu'il faut la
structurer différemment pour mettre en
évidence que là-dessus ce sera du bon
sens et tout le monde le reconnaîtra les
injonctions contradictoires parce que
personne ne s'y retrouve mais on peut
pas ma crainte c'est que demain ça
s'arrête et qu'on continue et qu'on
continue et qu'on remette des normes et
qu'on remette des superpositions
normatives et je vous rejoins vous avez
raison on a besoin d'un cadre mais je
suis pas sûr que au moment où tout cela
est très révélé dans la revendication et
à juste ce titre qu'on qu'on est mis en
œuvre ou qu'on prenne les moyens de de
résoudre ce problème là en agriculture
Merci à VOUS Daniel
Salm merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président le monde agricole est en
colère effectivement mais le monde
agricole est loin d'être homogène
aujourd'hui on a des énormes disparités
vous savez aussi bien que moi que 20 %
des agriculteurs captent 80 % des aides
de de la PAC et donc ça veut dire que
les 80 % autres se partage les 20 % et
ce ne sont pas que des producteurs que
des agriculteurs improductifs qu'est-ce
que vous pensez votre syndicat estce
qu'il soutient toujours les aides à
l'hectare ou pensez-vous qu'il faut
vraiment moduler cela que pensez-vous
aussi le plafonnement à combien
mettez-vous le plafonnement des aides
aujourd'hui pour qu'on ait une vraie une
vraie redistribution au niveau des
agriculteurs dans mon département devant
il y a des eu des manifestations devant
une lie devant du groupe
savancia aujourd'hui C ces groupes là
font pression pour diviser les
agriculteurs ne respecte pas les accords
cadres que peut-on faire pour que et
bien il y a pas cette volonté de de
diviser pour mieux régner et toujours
faire baisser le prix de des 1 lit de
lait on sait pourquoi ça dit capitalise
tout simplement parce que les agric ça
décapitalise en beauin tout simplement
parce que les agriculteurs n'y
retrouvent plus leur compte bien
entendu le libre échange dernière chose
qui qui qui vote les accords de libre
échange et où en est votre syndicat sur
ces accords de libre échange je vois
bien que il y a des des positions un peu
à géométrie variable est-ce que on doit
pas avoir un capte un peu plus clair et
puis la résilience on tape beaucoup sur
les normes alors on parle d'agrib j'ai
l'impression qu'en ce moment c'est
plutôt le décolo
bashing comment fait-on pour faire en
sorte que notre agriculture gagne en
résilience et soit propre à s'adapter au
réchauffement climatique merci voilà
monsieur le Président je vous laisse
répondre à ces questions merci je vais
commencer par répondre à la question du
sénateur Cardon sur le sur les marges de
la grande distribution bon
d'abord moi je au moment oùù je vous
parle je ne sais pas et donc j'ai
demandé à ce que le ministre ministre de
l'Économie Monsieur le Maire puisse à
nouveau comme il l'avait fait il y a un
an et demi diligeentter une enquête de
l'IGF l'inspection générale des finances
pour qu'on puisse avoir des chiffres
clairs parce que vous observez comme moi
que chacun explique que c'est pas lui
mais c'est l'autre et que il est
parfaitement en règle donc moi j'attends
d'avoir ces chiffres d'abord la première
chose c'est que j'espère qu'on va avoir
un transfert de marge vers vers
l'agriculture c'est c'est c'est ça que
je c'est ça mon boulot bon voilà donc
après je je je je je j'essaie d'être
équilibré là aussi tout le monde a
besoin de de vivre pour faire tomourner
les entreprises donc ce qu'on avait
observé lors de la je vais parler des
derniers chiffres de l'IGF en attendant
les prochains puisque le ministre a dit
qu'on devrait les avoir sous quelques
jours ou quelques semaines bon donc en
tous les cas la dernière fois on avait
constaté qu'il y avait un transfert et
c'est bien ainsi il était largement
temps puisqu'on avait eu 10 ans de
déflation auparavant
euh donc sur ce voilà par ailleurs pour
être précis l'encadrement des marges je
je je je voilà sur le plan législatif je
je pense que c'est un peu compliqué il y
en a d'autres qui demandent
l'administration des prix voilà je pense
que ça ça c'est c'est pas raisonnable
transparence mais c'est pas la même
chose que l'encadrement si je puis me
permettre euh voilà et donc la
transparence nous la demandons nous et
et et en fait il y a qu'une manière de
la voir assez rapidement c'est à travers
l'IGF parce qu'on a aussi un
observatoire des prix et des marges mais
qui a toujours 18 à 24 mois de de retard
et évidemment ce qui nous intéresse
c'est c'est de pouvoir regarder au
momenté ce qui nous intéresse aussi avec
la grande distribution et ça c'est des
demandes qu'on formule dans le moment
dans lequel on est c'est de faire en
sorte qu'il ait pas de négociation entre
l'industrie agroalimentaire et la grande
distribution tant qu'il y a pas eu un
accord entre les représentants des
professionnels les organisations de
producteurs je vais le faire un peu
rapide et le monde et le monde de
l'industrie agroalimentaire ça me paraît
important dans la construction du prix
en marche avant ça nous éviterait aussi
ce qu'on a en ce moment c'est-à-dire un
certain nombre de grandes entreprises
qui nous disent moi au regard de ce qui
est la difficulté de la négociation que
j'ai Ave avec l'industrie avec la grande
distribution je ne suis pas en mesure de
vous donner plus que voilà et et c'est
notamment le le cas dans le le lait
enfin voilà sans sans sans citer de
d'entreprise enfin concernant les
grandes distribution on a une inquiétude
parce qu'un certain nbre d'entre elles
se sont adapté à la loi les Français
font ça très très bien et sont
aujourd'hui en train de négocier dans le
cadre
européen voilà et et et du coup ce qui
nous intéresse c'est qu'on puisse
regarder comment cet esprit
peut évoluer pour ça on a besoin de
l'évolution du cadre européen donc il
faut qu'on regarde ça et du cadre
national donc ça ça fait partie des des
discussions qu'on a l'esprit c'est pas
que des produits alimentaires puissent
être négociés au niveau européen pour
arriver en France et détourner le cadre
de la loi c'est bien qu'on soit dans
l'esprit de la loi je note depuis
quelques jours une forme de bénévolence
de la grande distribution je m'en
réjouis voilà je trouve que il faudrait
qu'on s'évite ce ce type de moment de cè
et qu'on puisse avoir un peu de de
maturité il y a pas de naïveté dans mon
propos hein voilà mais pour nous la
question du prix elle est centrale voilà
je dis aussi que toutes les filières ne
sont pas encadrées par égalim voilà donc
je je je le dis pour pour qui peuvent
être des choix des filières elles-mêmes
voilà mais en tous les cas quand on
parle
d'élevage qui est le sujet qui nous
préoccupe en ce moment la question du
prix elle est centrale voilà et donc ça
ça va être regardé de de très très près
sur la question alors quel rôle pour le
ministère de l'Agriculture bon écoutez
moi je vais essayer de rester à ma place
voilà je moi j'ai besoin d'un
interlocuteur nous avons besoin d'un
interlocuteur on a maintenant un
ministère de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire on trouvait que
le signe était intéressant enfin ce qui
m'intéresse plus moi c'est l'efficacité
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui le budget du
ministère est essentiellement consacré à
l'enseignement agricole et et et et
l'enseignement agricole attire plus
qu'il n'attirait il y a quelques années
plutôt une bonne
nouvelle mais pour le reste le gros
c'est l'interface avec ce qui se passe à
Bruxelles dans les négociations de de
tous les toutes les directives et puis
dans dans ce que sont les grandes
politiques notamment la politique
agricole commune et puis après c'est
l'interface avec le ministère de
l'écologie le ministère de la Santé
enfin un certain nombre de ministères
dans lequel on a voilà donc comme vous
j'observe c'est pas complètement apaisé
et comme vous j'observe que parfois
c'est long et et peu eff moi je fais pas
de commentaire sur le ministre je je ne
les choisis pas je travaille avec et
ensuite je relève ou pas la possibilité
d'obtenir des résultats mais en tous les
cas il nous faut il nous faut un il nous
faut un ministère de tutelle ça me
paraît essentiel et dans le moment dans
lequel on est ça me paraît encore plus
évident
euh sur le sur l'agribashing bon écoutez
d'abord ce que j'observe c'est que il
est moins important que ce qu'on avait
il y a 3 ou 4 ans que les juges ont fait
ce qu'il fallait pour que les gens qui
suto aorise à envahir des élevages comme
ça dans des conditions enfin comme si on
rentrait chez vous bon tout ça est en
train de se tarer a quelques amendes un
peu un peu calibré qui ont été enfin il
y a des jugements en tous les cas qui
ont été rendus qui ont dissuadé de de de
ce type d'action bon c'est c'est pas
complètement terminé hein l'état voilà
mais enfin bon on onévitera jamais
quelques quelques excessifs euh mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que ça laissait des
traces et la
question du du bien-être en agriculture
c'est question centrale alors on
travaille maintenant avec Monsieur
damzin enfin Monsieur Cavel faisait
référence à ce qui avait été fait mais
voilà c'est un sujet qui doit se
poursuivre et qui et qui fait sur lequel
on a encore beaucoup de beaucoup de
travail et d'une manière générale c'est
ça rejoint le sujet de de de de la santé
mentale qui est un sujet qui dépasse le
cadre agricole je je le dis aussi hein
très largement et qui nous et qui nous
préoccupe sur les sujets alors élevage
réglementation bien oui mais là aussi je
voudrais être on voit comme vous la
décapitalisation de l'élevage et
singulièrement de l'élevage laitier il
nous reste aujourd'hui moins de 50000
éleveurs laitiers en France
et attirer des jeunes aujourd'hui en
leur expliquant que même avec un robot
de traite c'est quand même une astreinte
importante avec l'évolution de la
société c'est pas naturel même quand
vous êtes fils d'éleveur et que vous
aimeer ce métier et que vous avez bercé
dedans c'est pas complètement évident
parce que la vie sociale parce que la
volonté d'avoir aussi une vie comme tous
les Français de votre âge n'adhère pas
le consentement immédiat et et ça pose
aussi la question de la taille et moi je
je je pense qu'il faut pas du tout
éluder ce sujet demain des tailles
d'élevage plus importantes et j'ai pas
dit des tailles d'élevage voilà mais des
des tailles d'élevage plus importantes
ça permet des associations ça permet du
salariat et ça permet de pouvoir
profiter d'un weekend de temps en temps
d'un peu de repos ou de quelques jours
de vacances ce ce sujet il est il est
important dans la question de de
l'élevage
euh sur la réglementation j'en ai
largement parlé euh quand enfin un
ministère de la simplification écoutez
moi je je laisse ça à qui de droit moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
obtient comme résultat et qu'est-ce
qu'on est capable euh rapidement de
faire sauter je je note que chaque
gouvernement qui cesse explique que dans
sa période d'évolution il a pris x texte
x loi voilà donc on pèse au kilo on
travaille kil aujourd'hui très bien moi
j'aimerais qu'à un moment on puisse dire
aussi que la qualité passe par la
modération voyez et que et qu'on puisse
faire en sorte que de temps en temps on
se dise qu'il y a peut-être des choses
un peu à à nettoyer un peu comme chez
vous quand vous faites le grand ménage
et vous ouvrez des placards et vous
découvrez des choses que vous n'avez pas
utilisé depuis des années voilà donc on
a besoin de cet exercice voilà après
chacun reste dans son couloir de nage
moi je sais pas si c'est un ministère si
c'est un haut commissaire si c'est un
secrétaire je ne sais pas ce que je sais
c'est qu'on attend des résultats sur nos
fermes concernant
la la question du du sénateur salmon
alors là aussi le 2080 sur les zpac
c'est en Europe ça n'est pas le cas en
France donc non mais il faut faut qu'on
soit précis voilà donc je vous donne le
chiffre en France c'est 80 % des aides
pour 47 % des agriculteurs voilà donc je
compte sur vous maintenant
pour pour porter cette cette
information je dit comme je l'avais dit
au début vous avez aussi 100000
agriculteurs qui font moins de 25000 €
de production brute standard c'est pas
mes chiffres he c'est les chiffres de la
nation ils sont vérifiables évidemment
et donc vous voyez bien que aussi ça en
terme de volume d'aide voilà ça peut pas
être ça peut pas être comparable vous
posiez la question
euh de la redistribution mais est-ce
qu'on reste à hectare pas mais je je
vais venir je vais venir la question de
la redistribution donc au moment où je
vous parle la PAC prévoit déjà un volet
de redistribution puisque il y a
euh une surprime sur les premiers
hectares 52 premers hectares enfin bon
c'était un débat politique j'y reviens
pas mais en tous les cas il y a il y a
une une aide
supérieure pour les les les premiers
hectares ensuite sur les aides à
l'hectare aujourd'hui c'est le modèle
européen il y avait eu des questions sur
l'aide à à l'actif qui ont été soulevés
pourquoi pourquoi la France n'a pas
enfin pourquoi la FNSA contenté de mon
rôle pourquoi la FNS n'a pas assumé ça
parce que quand vous regardez les
chiffres aujourd'hui si on prend ce
modèle ceux qu'ont des actifs ce sont
les Roumains ce sont les Bulgares ce
sont des pays qui aujourd'hui
capteraient une part importante du
soutien sur cette base c'est un débat
qu'on a déjà eu des dizaines de fois y
compris à Bruxelles donc après on peut
dire on bascule à l'actif
voilà je je en tous les cas quand ça a
été fait la dernière fois ce sujet
conduis vis à un transfert massif vers
les gens qui sont encore
très très structurés en main d'œuvre
moins automatisé moins voilà et donc
très clairement on avait un transfert
assez massif voilà après l'aide à l'
hectare vous savez le sujet c'est
toujours de faire bouger les lignes tout
le monde dit bah maintenant on a qu'à
rayer la pâack et on va la réécrire
quand je vois la difficulté qu'on a eu à
Bruxelles mais vous aviez un député
européen à côté de vous donc il vous le
dira la difficulté à Bruxelles de
trouver
éid nous questionous ça nous questionne
nous mais on l' écrit on l'a dit voil y
avait à l'époque la promesse que les PSN
les projets stratégiques nationaux ser
comparé politiquement entre je suis au
regret de constater que ça n'a pas été
le cas mais c'était l'engagement qui é
pris voil et ça c'est pas donc
aujourd'huié retard la réforme s'est
fait très dans la enfin en tous les cas
à la fin dans la précipitation tout le
monde rendait on essa d'aller nous on
demandait qu'on puisse avoir les règles
parce qu'il y avait aussi des règles
d'application de la PAC et d'ailleurs
dont on découvre quelques écueils
aujourd'hui puisqueau moment où je vous
parle une de nos demandes là c'est que
les 5 à 7 % de dossiers qui ne sont pas
ou partiellement réglés puissent l'être
et on découvre quelques écueils je vous
en donne un il était prévu que pour
éviter que des gens puissent bénéficier
d'ê PAC jusqu'à 80 ans 90 ans voilà
on est à partir de des régimes de
retraite voilà le fait qu'on puisse plus
toucher d'pac et là qu'est-ce qu'on
constate on constate que quelques
dossiers de gens qui parce que par
exemple la conjointe a travaillé dans la
fonction publique hospitalière par
exemple les trois quatre premières
années de sa vie elle a aujourd'hui 64
ou 65 ans son régime est purgé
automatiquement elle touche 120 € par
mois ou 100 € par mois ou 80 € de de de
sa période de travail de quelques années
au début de sa carrière et là poum il y
a plus d' pack voilà et là on dit bah
non c'est pas l'esprit du texte là on
dit bah oui mais on sait pas comment on
va faire fa qu'on le fasse à la main
voilà bon je je je vous dis ça aussi
parce que derrière et je fais référence
à ce qui a été dit c'est des hommes et
des femmes voilà c'est pas que des
machines et de l'argent et voilà donc il
y a des gens aujourd'hui qui sont dans
dans la panade donc la redistribution je
vous ai parlé
sur sur les les les accords commerciaux
et le fait que il y a quelques
entreprises vous avez cité saintvencia
moi je n'en cite pas parce que en fait
ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas le le nchem
c'est l'efficacité du dispositif voilà
nous on a besoin encore une fois et je
le dis ici parce que souvent on explique
que l'industrie l'agroindustrie c'est
pas bien puis alors moi je sais de quoi
je parle voilà quand on a un litre de
lait quand vous avez une brique de lait
quand vous avez un kil de farine quand
vous avez une bouteille d'huile sur
votre table elle est pas arrivée du
champ de l'agriculteur ou de la ou ou ou
de la stabulation elle est pas arrivée
directement sur votre table et donc on a
besoin de partenairire industriel non
mais je je l c'est pas évident pour tout
le monde donc hors les fruits légumes et
le miel tout a à peu près besoin de
passer entre les mains d'une industrie
alors je sais que l'industrie c'est pas
très moderne en France aujourd'hui mais
enfin nous on en a besoin voilà bon donc
ce qui nous intéresse c'est non mais oui
mais vous voyez bien le sujet le sujet
c'est la marche vous avez raison
monsieur le sénateur non mais vous
critique pas moi j'entends toute la
journée que parce que au titre de la
profession agricole je préside un groupe
industriel qui transforme nos graines de
cols et tournesol en huile je serai le
représentant du du grand capital je me
permets devant les représentants de la
nation que vous êtes de d'éclaircir le
point voilà et donc ce qui m'intéresse
moi ce qui m'intéresse moi c'est de
prouver que on a besoin de
transformation on a besoin que ce soit
fait en France parce que la
transformation elle peut se faire
ailleurs et revenir chez nous c'est
notamment le cas dans la pomme de terre
quand vous êtes à la frontière belge
vous produisez les prommes de terre la
valeur ajoutée est fait en Belgique et
vous rachetez les chips en France
peut-être qu'on peut être plus
intelligent que ça et se dire que on
fait ça je dis ça ça parce que le sujet
c'est pas tel ou tel entreprise c'est
c'est le mode de négociation et donc là
je redis ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
pour nous il faut d'abord qu'il y a une
négociation entre les producteurs et
l'industriel et qu'ensuite en marge en
marche avant on puisse avoir la no avec
la grande distribution ça pose aussi la
question du consentement au paiement de
l'alimentation du modèle français voilà
qui est aussi un sujet central vous ne
l'avez pas abordé je m'autorise à le
faire tout le monde nous demande
aujourd'hui de l'alimentation de qualité
de proximité et de la naturalité le
consentement au paiement je je le
constate voilà je pourrais parler de
l'agriculture ologique qui traverse une
crise majeure majeure parce que
aujourd'hui le marché en tous les cas la
demande n'est pas là et qu'on se bat à
la FNSEA pour sauver ce qu'on peut
sauver en ce moment des entreprises et
que quand on nous explique qu'il faudra
qu'on en ait quasiment le double dans 6
ans ça ne nous paraît pas raisonnable au
moment où on est dans le contexte dans
lequel on est voilà et que ce qui ce qu'
qu'on souhaite c'est sauver les
entreprises qui aujourd'hui se posent la
question de se déconvertir et et et et
c'est le cas et c'est le cas
enfin vous avez posé une question sur le
libre échange les accords de libre
échange je croyais que j'avais répondu
je vais essayer de préciser mon mon
propos nous ne sommes pas hostiles au
commerce aux échanges nous ne sommes pas
pour fermer les frontières pour les
raisons que je vous ai dit on a parlé de
viticulture tout à l'heure nous ce qui
nous inquiète c'est les sujets qui
concernent la réciprocité ce qu'on
observe aujourd'hui c'est que de mettre
des clauses de sauvegarde qui sont
juridiquement costaud de mettre des
normes de réciprocité ce qu'on a appelé
les clos miroirs à Bruxelles qui sont
quand même un peu compliqués à mettre en
œuvre un peu compliqués à mettre en
œuvre et enfin les contrôles qui sont
quasi inexistants sur l'importation des
denrées alimentaire moins de 3 % de ce
qui rentre en denrée alimentaire en
Europe fait l'objet de contrôle nous
questionne voilà ce qu'on dit euh après
moi je suis pas à l' douanes je voilà et
puis je suis pas compétent pour en
parler je dis juste que il y a une vraie
appréhension de ça maintenant moi en
tant que consémateur de manger de la
mozzarella italienne ou un bout de
serérano espagnol ou de boire un café le
matin ça ça me pose pas de problème et
donc expliquer qu'on va produire du café
en France demain est pas complètement
réaliste donc voilà j'essaie de j'essaie
pardon oui mais voilà vous avez on sait
faire plein de choses même du jambon on
sait le faire aussi voilà mais acceptons
qu'il puisse y avoir aussi d'autres
produits qui font une alimentation de
qualité
voilà merci monsieur le Président alors
Guilin Cambier Jean-Marc Boyer
Antoinette Gul Guil merci madame la
Présidente je vais essayer d'être rapide
et le plus court possible je me suis
rendu comme beaucoup d'entre nous sur
les points de blocage de de nos
exploitants agricoles j'ai des questions
tant philosophiques que que pratique
d'abord très pratique au pratique j'ai
entendu beaucoup de la part des des
exploitants trois choses revenir ou
ressortir les lourdeurs administratives
françaises les loi l'application de la
loi égalim et les normes euh est-ce que
sur ces ces points là par exemple vous
avez eu depuis que vous échang vous êtes
en échange continu avec le gouvernement
depuis la semaine passée est-ce que vous
avez eu des avancées concrètes deème
deuxème
question un peu un peu plus général la
pack qui était une véritable réussite
européenne et qui était un marqueur de
la construction
européenne provoque en effet un certain
nombre de de questionnements est-ce que
vous pensez que la vision européenne de
l'agriculture est telle qu'elle est
porté également par la France serait
serait à revoir et enfin 3è question
puisque il me semble avoir constaté sur
les points de blocage des divergences de
vue on va dire ça comme ça entre les
exploitants agricooles comment est-ce
que vous la Fédération vous essayez de
porter l'unicité du mouvement et de la
parole agricole merci Jean-Marc
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
pour votre pour votre
présence sur le terrain effectivement on
rencontre des agriculteurs qui sont
excédés excédés par des règles
incohérentes irrité par des excès de ail
de l'administration qui fait appliquer
des des consignes qui ne sont pas du
tout qui sont totalement incohérentes
par des des fonctionnaires Alés dans la
proposition de loi de mon collègue
leurenduplan répondre à la crise
agricole il est proposé la suppression
de l'fb est-ce que quel quelle est votre
position par rapport à cette cette
proposition qui me paraît très très
importante dans le cadre des des
motivations que peuvent avoir les
agriculteurs actuellement deuxème
question on parle beaucoup des règles de
surtransposition euh en France j'ai pas
souvenir moi d'avoir voté des règles de
surtransposition dans notre assemblée et
donc qui décide aujourd'hui d'après vous
de ces règles de surtransposition qui
sont appliquées effectivement et qui
posent de réels problèmes 3è question
j'ai été très choqué de voir des blindés
face pass au tracteur on a connu les
ametiers en cagoulet qui cassaient tout
dans les rues de Paris et ailleurs avec
des tirs de mortiers sur les forces sur
les forces de l'ordre et les
agriculteurs sont des gens quand même
raisonnables or le symbole est quand
même fort et je trouve complètement
déplacé donc quel est votre sentiment
par rapport à cette à cette opération
Antoinette oui madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président de la question va
porter sur les pesticides en 2021
l'incerne donc l'Institut national de la
santé et de la recherche a rendu publ un
rapport qui un rapport sur l'effet des
pesticides démontrant qu'il y a un lien
entre l'exposition au pesticides et la
santé des agriculteurs et a survenu
notamment de trois types de cancer le
cancer de la prostate le miélome
multiple et le lymphome
nonnien donc ma question question est la
suivante la lutte contre les pesticides
chimiques devrait être un combat commun
que vous devriez porter au côté des
écologiste que nous sommes je voulais
savoir quel était votre positionnement
sur ce point précis car nous voyons que
les premières victimes des pesticides ce
sont les agriculteurs ensuite bien sûr
les citoyens je vous remercie voilà
c'est à vous monsieur le Président merci
madame la Présidente donc sur la
question du du sénateur crambier donc
sur les les lourdeurs les normes bon
vous avez raison he c'est ce qui
aujourd'hui a été le le déclencheur bon
au moment où je vous parle je n'ai pas
de certitude qui ont été annoncé par le
Premier ministre et ses services nous on
a dit ce qu'on souhaitait voilà sur un
certain nombre de de de de
surtransposition qu'ell soit d'origine
enfin qu'elle soit faite sur le plan
européens avec des règles européennes
qu'on qu' qu'on surtranspose en France
hein notamment sur les pesticides mais
on en dir un mot je vais vous répondre
madame et et puis sur toutes les normes
bon je vous ai parlé de la laine de
mouton mais je je peux vous en voilà le
sujet en fait ce qui est difficile c'est
c'est c'est le changement de culture
c'est dire que moi je fais pas de
commentaire sur les fonctionnaires je
pense que les fonctionnaires ils font le
boulot qu'on leur demande de faire
est-ce qu'on est capable à un moment de
se dire qu'à chaque fois qu'on met
quelque chose on puisse un l'étalonner
et dire qu'est-ce que ça remplace voilà
si on dit bah il faut tel type de norme
qu'est-ce qu'on de quoi on a plus besoin
in et comment on le fait on ne se pose
jamais la question et en fait ce qui est
difficile mais l'administration
elle-même parfois se retrouve avec des
grilles de lecture qui font que ce n'est
pas les mêmes en fonction des
départements donc c'est ça qui nous
questionne et nous on dit mais il y a un
moment il faut faire simple j'avais pris
mais je me rappelle monsieur le sénateur
on avait parlé des ha ensemble la
question de la ha c'est c'est c'est
c'est question un peu voilà tout le
monde dit ça a du sens il faut en mettre
voilà bon 14 12 ou 14 parties texte
règlements qui vont dessus niveau
européen quand on parle Directive
Habitat quand on parle directive oiseau
niveau français date on touche pas une
voilà bon et on comprend pas pourquoi
les agriculteurs veulent pas implantter
donc moi j'ai essayé de faire l'exégèse
j'ai essayé d'expliquer qu'à un moment
quand vous n'en avez pas et que vous
avez pas d'ennui vous avez pas forcément
envie de vous en créer alors que pour
autant sur le plan agronomique ou de la
biodiversité ça peut avoir du sens puis
après on peut même parler de de
l'intérêt économique de la ha comment
avec une e deain on peut produire de la
biomasse on peut faire des choses mais
il faut il faut que voilà mais il faut
que tout ça se cadre avec des filières
aujourd'hui on est incapable de parler
de ça incapable de parler de ça voilà
donc nous on essaie d'avancer le Premier
ministre a annoncé que il ferait un seul
texte alors moi je sais pas si c'est un
seul qui reprend les 14 ou si voilà donc
c'est on a très envie de discuter du
contenu au moment où je vous parle je ne
sais pas de quoi je parle donc j'ai
entendu l'annonce mais bon donc tout ce
qui sera de nature à nous faciliter la
vie il ira dans le bon sens je redis
pour éviter les excès on n pas dit que
il y avait plus de normees qu'on a pas
dit qu'il y avait plus de règles et que
c'était n'importe quoi voilà je je bon
sur la PAC bon le sujet c'est pas la PAC
le sujet c'est c'est le paquet vert
c'est le Green Deal donc nous qu'est-ce
qu'on dit on dit ce paquet a été discuté
en
2019 à un moment où ni le covid ni la
guerre en Ukraine n'était conscientisé
peut-être qu'il y avait des visionnaires
parmi vous enfin globalement les gens
n'avaient pas conscience de ça ce qui
nous gêne c'est sa déclinaison agricole
qui a un volet clairement mais c'est pas
moi qui le dis c'est un certain nombre
d'études d'impact y compris la
commission qui fait peser un poids sur
la production alors on pourrait dire
après tout on l'assume sauf que on est
dans un moment où on fait rentrer
d'Ukraine des denrées en proportion
importantes et y compris on importe
aujourd'hui de l'ordre d'un tiers de
notre alimentation en France c'est même
le cas en bio je le dis un/3 du bio
aujourd'hui consommé et du bio importé
c'est pas une tard d'importer simplement
on peut pas nous faire un procès en
productivisme et en et et en espèce
d'excès voilà qu quand par
ailleurs l'Europe et singulièrement la
France qui est un en tous les cas j'ai
encore la faiblesse de le penser un
grand pays agricole importe un tiers de
son alimentation donc le sujet c'est de
rediscuter de la vision que porte ce
texte je dis aussi parce que j'entends
des gens qui disent on va tout mettre à
la poubelle on va recommencer de à Z il
y a des sujets qui demeureront le sujet
du défi climatique c'est pas un sujet
qui va disparaître que ça'appelle le
Green Deal ou ou autre chose c'est un
sujet que les agriculteurs observe au
quotidien les sujets autour de la
biodiversité c'est des sujets sur
lequels on a aussi envie de de de
regarder mais je le dis dans le moment
dans lequel on est il faut qu'on puisse
dire voilà et la Pâque ne sera que la
déclinaison de je doute pas d'ailleurs
qu'elle sera ouverte à moyenne ou courte
moyenne échéance parce que il faudra
qu'on rediscute de ça je le dis aussi
dans un moment où on a quand même un
rôle jeis quand même parler du rôle
export parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé
voilà on a des sujets notamment sur le
pourtour mit ranéen d'alimentation qui
sont très importants alors on peut dire
aussi on laisse les Russes et puis nous
c'est plus notre problème mais derrière
ça derrière la question alimentaire il y
a aussi toute la question de la
géopolitique et de la manière dont
l'Europe envisage son rôle moi j'entends
j'entends quand
même l'Europe dire sur le continent
africain on a une responsabilité il y a
de la coopération dans des proportions
très importantes bah la question
alimentaire elle fait partie de
l'équation je dis pas que c'est la seule
on peut pas écarter ça sur l'unicité du
mouvement agricole voilà alors là aussi
tout moi on me répète depuis 10 jours
vous êtes en train de vous faire
déborder par la base vouis vous dire
d'abord 1 le monde agricole c'est le
monde qui est le plus syndqué de tous
les secteurs économiques voilà plus que
plus que les ouvriers plus que les
cadres plus que les agents de maîtrise
c'est nous c'est chez nous qui a le plus
environ 40
% prenez ce chiffre avec un peu de
reculon donc effectivement il y a 60 %
de gens qui sont pas syndiqués mais
quand vousand manifestation sur la
réforme des retraites je suis pas sûr
non plus que tout le monde est sa carte
voilà mon sujet c'est pas de savoir qui
est syndiqué ou pas mon sujet c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on porte pour l'agriculture
française bon on a deux compétiteurs
syndicaux bah c'est plutôt bien comme ça
les gens ils ont le choix voilà bon don
qui aujourd'hui clairement je parle de
la Coordination
Rurale porte des revendications en tous
les cas je suis pas là pour faire leur
promotion hein ils se débrouilleront
avec le gouvernement je sais qu'ils vont
être reçus donc ils diront ce qu'ils ont
à dire mais mais mais voilà qui qui qui
qui ne sont pas enfin moi depuis 10
jours pouvez reprendre meses mes propos
publics j'appelle tout le monde au calme
à une forme voilà je je m'honore au
moment où je vous parle qu'il ait pas de
policier blessés qu'il ait pas de
gendarme blessés que les choses soient
tenues est-ce que ça tiendra je ne sais
pas et effectivement peut-être qu'à un
moment les choses partiront mais voilà
je constate aussi que le gouvernement
est bien content de trouver un
interlocuteur avec qui discuter on est
peut-être pas des gens fréquentables
mais finalement quand il y a personne
autour de la table c'est pas c'est c'est
c'est pas facile non plus on est dans un
pays où le dialogue social a quand même
une place nous on a toujours assumé ça
ça fait 78 ans qu'on existe voilà
qu'après le gouvernement discute avec
d'autres bah c'est son rôle moi j'ai pas
de commentaire à faire et donc que que
le monde agricole soit pas monoliique ça
on le sait depuis longtemps à la
FNSEA je suis saliier le premier
vice-président de la FNSEA est un
viticulteur le deuxième est un
producteur de viande bovine du Cantal on
a toutes les productions tous les
territoires toutes les typologies
d'exploitation et je vous prie de croire
que peut-être comme dans cette maison de
temps en temps il y a des discussions un
peu animées ce qui fait notre force
c'est qu'à un moment on essaie de faire
des
synthèses voilà qu'est-ce que voulez je
vous dise si un moment les gens veulent
une forme de radicalité ils le feront
enfin encore une fois c'est une histoire
de conviction moi j'ai pas peur d'être
minoritaire ça me pose pas de problème
vous voyez ce que je veux dire nous on a
dit quoi on a dit que un on restait
européen c'est important de l'entendre
dans le moment dans lequel on est on dit
pas vous avez compris depuis le début de
mon propos que je dis pas que ce que
fait la Commission et ce qui a été
décidé idée nous va voilà et même on
comprend pas à certains moments et c'est
pas pour autant qu'il faut pas continuer
à penser la question agricole et
alimentaire en européen parce que en
face de nous quand vous parlez du
continent américain quand vous parlez
des chinoisou quand vous parlez des
Russes il faut quand même qu'on soit un
tout petit peu lucide sur ce qui se
passe
ensuite qu'est-ce qu'on dit on dit que
la question du revenu et de la
production sont des questions qui sont
centrales et ça a été dit les revenus
peuvent être très différents dans
l'agriculture et même je vais même être
très clair avec vous heureusement qu'il
y a des agriculteurs qui gagnent bien
leur vie et je je leur dis tous les
jours c'est pas une tare parce que la
vision de l'agriculteur français qui
serait forcément quelqu'un qui serait
dans la souffrance c'est pas non plus
très attractif au moment où il va
falloir qu'on attire des générations
quel que soit on parle toujours du du
modèle agricole mais ça me fait sourire
parce que il suffit de connaître les
territoires et je crois que je suis avec
des gens qui les connaissent un peu pour
se rendre compte que l'agriculture
bretonne n'est pas la même que
l'agriculture du Massif Central qu'être
seralier dans le Bassin parisien c'est
pas la même chose que d'être seralier
dans le laoraget et que d'être
transfrontalier pardon d'être
agriculteur frontalier c'est c'est pas
la même ENF voilà donc la la typicité
elle est très différente dans une même
production dans une même production
faire du lait de montagne ou faire du
lait en Bretagne c'est pas la même chose
voilà bon donc ça c'est aussi je crois
notre force c'est notre force donc moi
je cherche pas voilà nous ce qu'on veut
c'est porter un message clair et d'être
des interlocuteurs crédibles voilà après
les agriculteurs ils attendent pas du
président de la FNSA et de la fnsoa qu'
leur disent qu'ils ont à faire tous les
jours le sujet c'est que si demain il y
a plus d'interlocuteur on repasse dans
un épisode gilet
jaune peut-être que c'est ce qui se
passera peut-être que dans 5 jours c'est
ce qui se passera voilà après le sujet
c'est qu'est-ce qui s'est passé 3 ans ou
2 ans après les gilets jaunes moi il
faut leur demander je reste dans mon
domaine de compétence qui est
l'agriculture donc voilà on détient pas
la vérité on porte des revendications
elles sont claires elles sont posées sur
la table d'autres en ont d'autres
d'autres défendre leurs intérêts encore
une fois ce qui compte c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on est capable de faire et je n'ai
nous n'avons jamais prétendu à la FNSEA
être omniscient et omnipotent mais en
même temps on a une histoire en ce
moment je pense que tout le monde est
bien content qu'on soit là parce que au
moins on sait avec qui discuter et puis
après s'il y en a d'autres et ben le
gouvernement fera ses choix le Premier
ministre me demande pas l'autorisation
quand il veut recevoir quelqu'un donc
voilà je je suis très clair sur le sujet
je veux pas qu'il ait de voilà ensuite
la question du du sénateur Boyer bon les
règles incohérentes les les voilà je
pense que j'ai un peu déjà voilà sur
l'ofb
vous me dites est-ce que la fnsoa
demande la suppression
deofb bon l'ofb c'est un vrai irritant à
la fnsoa parce qu'en fait c'est la
relation qui est pas comprise bon
personne ne pense que demain enfin s'il
y a plus l' FB qu'il y aura pas de sujet
autour de la police de l'eau ouou la
police de l'environnement enfin c'est
pas sérieux de le penser bon donc la
question pour nous c'est quel relation
entre ces gens et et la profession
agricole alors il y a tout un tas de
sujets ont été mis sur la table les
sujets de la relation entre le
contrôleur et le contrôl les sujets des
méthodes voilà bon premier élément
qu'est-ce qu'on a demandé on a demandé
que que ce corps puisse être attaché au
préfet les préfets sont les
représentants de l'État voilà et que
donc le préfet puisse
avoir euh une discussion avec l' FB et
que ça soit pas seulement dans une
relation avec le procureur de la
République ça nous paraî important ça se
passe comme ça avec les forces de
l'ordre ça se passe comme ça avec les
forces de l'ordre voilà donc après tout
ça ça nous pas important et et je le dis
on a entendu une demande forte aussi du
côté des préfets voilà mais sans vous
interrompre je crois que ça a été fait
dans la loi 3DS aujourd'hui les préfets
sont les référents départementaux de
l'ofb vous avez raison c'est dans la loi
3DS mais en fait c'est pas appliqué
voilà c'est ça parce que les préfets ne
s' saaisissent pas et vous voyez c'est
c'est non non
non bon mais attendez bon moi je fais
pas de commentairire de cette nature je
je dis juste que aujourd'hui
effectivement il y avait quelque chose
dans la 3DS mais ça n'est pas appliqué
ça n'est pas appliqué et donc dans la
discussion qu'on a aussi avec le Premier
ministre c'est on dit qu'est-ce qui fait
que les textes qui sont pris sont
appliqués parce que ça aussi c'est
interrogé agriculteurs moi j'ai un sujet
de confiance en ce moment les gens me
disent tous de toute façon on se fait
avoir depuis des années ils nous disent
que et on se fera voir moi il y a un
moment il faut bien qu'on s'appuie sur
des élément tangibles sinon sinon après
bah sinon après on n plus dans le cadre
on change de cadre bon donc ça c'est
important donc rattachement au préfet et
le Premier ministre a proposé qu'on se
mette autour de la table pour voir
comment on pourrait avoir des discussion
autour
euh parce que il y a deux métiers il y a
le métier administratif puis il y a le
métier répressif en tous les cas voilà
donc c'est pas la même chose donc
comment comment on intervient dans ces
deux métiers comment on le fait avec
avec quel cadre mais en tous les cas ce
sujet il est très attendu par le monde
agricole sur euh les blindés face au
tracteurs bon écoutez moi je je tout ça
est tout ça est un voilà nous on a dit
où on se mettait il y a rien qui a été
fait sans qu'on en ait parlé au préfet
avant on est en en lien avec les
autorités pour que les choses soient
encadrées un moment les autorités
souhaitent mettre des blindés en face
des tracteurs tout ça enfin je vais vous
dire chacun fait son métier nous on fait
le nôtre et je vais vous dire si ça
devait mal tourner ce que je ne souhaite
absolument pas c'est pas de blinder
voyez le sujet n pas de cette nature
donc tout le monde tout tout le monde
tout le monde fait voilà l'État exerce
son autorité
donae voilà je je voilà nous on essaie
de faire en sorte qu'il ait pas de
débordement et je le redis depuis le
début on essaie de tenir une ligne
plutôt de responsabilité voilà c'est pas
facile je ne sais pas si ça tiendra mais
en tous les cas pour ce qui nous
concerne on est très clair sur la
question madame la sénatrice sur les
pesticides alors bon ce sujet anime je
je vais vous dire en tant qu'agriculteur
ce qui est mon sujet moi pour produire
aujourd'hui j'ai besoin dans un sombre
de cas de pesticides c'est une charge
pour moi si demain je peux m'en passer
je vous le dis je le ferai sans aucun
problème je vous ai dit qu'on était dans
une des agricultures les plus durables
au monde donc je regarde aussi ce qui se
fait
ailleurs je dis que si on peut trouver
demain des méthodes alternatives
l'agronomie qui est en train de revenir
très fort la question des sols la
question des couvertures si on peut
trouver des biostimulants de la
protection de toute nature on y est prêt
même d'autres produits il y a deux
sujets sous-jacents première c'est la
trajectoire la deuxème c'est
l'investissement pour trouver les
solutions parce que quand on dit par
exemple on retire une matière active
pour des raisons de toxicologie ce que
je peux comprendre par que vous l'avez
dit vousmême on est utilisateur
voilà non
mais j'ai même pas parlé d' pour le
moment je dis quand il y a une décision
publique de retrait de molécule moi je
considère que si elle est mauvaise en
France elle est aussi pour un Allemand
et un Belge voilà c'est pas ce que
j'observe aujourd'hui voyez-vous donc ça
ça questionne c'estd que je vais prendre
l'exemple des néonicotinoïdes je je
voilà l'acétappride qui est un
néonicotinoïde aujourd'hui est utilisé
en Allemagne en traitement et rien je
vous invite à le vérifier voilà bon donc
qui qui qui est de notre point de vue
pire que en traitement de semence de
betterave par exemple peu importe c'est
une décision qui a été prise donc
aujourd'hui vous avez unintérieur de
l'Europe des homologations de matièrees
Activ qui sont européennes toutes passe
par l'fsa ça c'est voilà et après vous
avez des autorisations de mise en marché
qui sont nationales je redis que si à un
moment il y a une molécule qui pose
problème elle pose pas problème à un
français et pas un Allemand ou pas un
Belge voilà premier élément ensuite je
dis que sur la recherche et l'innovation
il faut mettre des moyen rapidement je
l'ai dit le PDG lineray le
sait moi j'ai besoin de tous les acteurs
je le redis aussi public privé hors
Europe faut mettre les meilleurs autour
de la table pour qu'on trouve les
solutions parce que en revanche
qu'onacceptera pas c'est notamment ce
qui se passait en Ciz c'est dire il y a
une molécule on la retire vous avez une
petit un petit insecte là qui s'appelle
la drosophile qui vient piquer les
cerises qui les rend impropre à la
consommation al pas de manière
systématique je rentre pas dans les
détails mais voilà et qui conduit à des
pertes de production cette année très
importantes et à de l' alors 100 % dans
certains endroits pas partout voilà et
qui conduit à de l'importation et est-ce
que est-ce que le consommateur français
ou parisien qui va trouver des cerises
turques bien brillantes bien poli sur
son étal qui ont elles-même eu cette
matière active sort grandi de cette
discussion je ne le crois pas voilà bon
donc le sujet de qu'on a synthétiser de
manière très rapide dans pas
d'interdiction sans solution c'est
quelque chose qui est important pour
nous c'est quelque chose qui est
important pour nous moi je je suis pas
le représentant de telle ou telle FME je
dis que j'ai besoin de de solution
technique la betterave est un cas moi
sur ma ferme en 2020 j'ai eu de la
jaunice j'ai fait 20 % du rendement que
je fais d'habitude j'ai besoin de
solution il y a un pnri qui a été fait
avec des investissements pour essayer de
trouver des méthodes alternatives y
compris par la génétique je le dis parce
qu'à Bruxelles on a des discussion en ce
moment sur les NBT les nouvelles
techniques de sélection et on voit bien
que ça fait débat entre ce bien sûr
entre ceux qui qui considèrent que je le
fais à peine de manière caricaturelle
que ce sont les nouveaux OGM et ceux qui
disent que quand même la mutagénèse a du
sens pour accélérer la recherche et
permettre que demain on est aussi sans
brevet le vivant c'est l'agriculteur qui
vous le dit on est des solutions pour
avoir des plantes qui
soient plus résistantes à des attaques
d'insectes à des attaques de champignons
peut-être même au problématiqu
climatique ça a du sens pour nous voilà
parce que moi j'ai besoin besoin de
solution et si la solution c'est on
produit plus et on importe ben je ne
l'accepte pas voilà j'essaie de vous le
dire comme ça et encore une
fois je voudrais aussi qu'on donne acte
des progrès qui ont été enregistrés
depuis 20 ans parce que ce qui est
difficile aussi et ça ça fait partie des
discussions c'est qu'en fait à chaque
fois on dit fait des efforts mais jamais
on dit bon il y a eu des progrès fait
quand on regarde ce progrès qui ont été
fait sur les cmr1 sur les cmr2 il faut
un moment pour qu'on continue et qu'on
ait une dynamique qu'on donne acte des
progrès enregistrés voilà je le dis
et il y a pas une solution miracle ce
sera une combinaison de solutions et ça
c'est important et c'est pour ça que je
redis que ce qui est important c'est de
continuer à produire et ceux qui disent
c'est zéro phyo faut
rien sont pas sont pas raisonnables
voilà je vous le dis comme je le pense
Anne Catherine Loisier Amel gaker et
Yannick Jade ou merci président all est
très vite beaucoup de choses ont été dit
donc avec les de niveau de de
questionnement et d'attente au niveau
intérieur et au niveau plus européen au
niveau intérieur vous avez évoqué donc
la l'application des des lois égalim
j'attire juste en complément votre
attention sur le fait que dans la la
restauration hors domicile il y avait
aussi des engagements de l'État pas
seulement dans les cantines scolaires
mais dans les l'administration de l'État
dans les prisons les hôpitaux et autres
et et même des engagements qui allaient
jusqu'à 100 % de viand bovine pris à
l'époque par Julien Normandie donc voilà
je pense que sur ces volets là il y a il
y a un levier vraiment sur lequel il
faut insister euh question à ce stade du
débat sera juste sur le le volile
européen la la singularité c'est qu'on a
quand même là une mobilisation je pense
comme jamais c'està-dire que c'est 18
derniers mois c'est pratiquement 16 ou
17 pays enfin les agriculteurs de de
nombreux pays européens qui se sont
mobilisés donc il y a il y a une vraie
remise en cause on va le dire de la de
la de la stratégie agricole
européenne donc est-ce que vous sentez
que là il y a un levier particulier pour
remettre nous ce que nous demandons nous
l'avons demandé à plusieurs reprises de
remettre farm tout fou sur la table de
remettre aussi aujourd'hui la la la
stratégie de gestion de de de l'Ukraine
enfin de notre soutien à l'Ukraine parce
que si demain on répond sur les
problèmes intérieurs mais que cette
situation là elle demeure je pense que
on reverra nos agriculteurs dans dans
quelques mois dans le même difficulté
Amel merci madame la Présidente beaucoup
de choses ont été dites je vais je vais
juste aborder la problématique des
filières exclusivement régionales qui
rencontrent de graves difficultés
difficultés qui mettent en danger la
toalité de production en fait française
et et ce à court terme je vais parler de
ce que je connais évidemment le mieux
dans ma région 95 % desendis voilà sont
produit dans les Haut- de France mais il
n'y a pas que la betterave le CH de
Bruxelles et et clairement des fières
aujourd'hui en danger qui doivent
également bénéficier en fait de plan
d'urgence au même titre que celui qui a
été évoqué pour la viticulture il s'agit
surtout pas d'opposer les cultures ce
que je dis juste c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
faut des réponses pour tous une question
allez-vous aller jusque là dans vos
conditions d'arrêt du mouvement que nous
soutenons bien sûr je vous remercie
Yannick jado merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président vous conviendrez
quand même que si le Green Deal et tout
ce qui est autour du Green Deal peut
susciter des inquiétudes ça ne peut en
aucun cas être mis comme responsable de
la crise actuelle puisqu'on parle au
fond de choses qui potentiellement vont
se mettre en œuvre on est d'accord que
cette crise aujourd'hui elle est longue
elle est structurelle elle est
extrêmement dure et c'est pour ça que
que nous la soutenons mais il faut qu'on
fasse attention aussi les uns et les
autres dans les arguments qu'on met
qu'on met en avant un point de
clarification sur au fond le débat sur
l'exception agricole qui a été prononcé
par le premier ministre et notamment
dans nos relation au commerce
international bon il y a pas besoin
d'accord de libre échange pour vendre du
vin ça se boit à peu près partout dans
le monde et c'est et c'est tant mieux et
c'est notre et c'est notre fierté on
voit les clauses miroir on les défend
moi j'ai toujours combattu les accords
de libre échange on les défend on voit
quand c'est le merour qu'est-ce que vous
dites sur l'agneau néo-zélandais parce
qu'il y a pas de d'enjeu de close
miroire l'élevage extensif néozélandais
au fond même rendu en Europe il est plus
écolo que dans les dans les évaluations
que l'agneau français et moi je défends
que on protège l'agneau français contre
l'agneau néozélandais qui a pas faire
20000 km pour un carré d'agneau donc au
fond comment vous situez par rapport à
ce type d'accord où au fond l'enjeu
c'est pas la clause miroir c'est le
principe du commerce international sur
des produits alimentaires liés à nos
filières et puis un point si vous le
voulez bien on a beaucoup parlé de la
décapitalisation dans le secteur bin et
laitier notamment est-ce que vous
regrettez en tant que FNSEA finalement
d'avoir participé
à la suppression des cotas laitiers qui
était quand même un instrument de
régulation du lait de stabilisation des
revenus des éleveurs et finalement
d'avoir joué le marché international ça
a plus déstabiliser les éleveurs et
renforcer
l'actalice monsieur le Président alors
sur la question de madame la sénatrice
Loisier de la mobilisation
européenneon moi je pense que ça ne
changera pas les choses avant tion au
mois de de juin voilà je pense que tout
le monde est en train de constater
l'échec c'estàd que voilà euh je vous
dis on est en fin de mandature la
présidente fayenne elle-même qui avait
assez peu parlé d'agriculture dans les
premières années de son mandat commence
à comprendre que peut-être il y a un
sujet de cette
nature je vois que l'ensemble des
parties prenantes ne se satisfont pas de
cette situation pour des parfois des
points de vues très opposés euh voilà
mais les les différents groupes
parlementaires qui composent le
Parlement européen voient bien la
situation dans laquelle on est et cette
situation vous l'avez dit est inédite
moi je je n'ai pas souvenir qu'on est
autant depuis 1992 et les grands débats
sur l'avenir de la PAC je n'ai pas
souvenir d'une telle mobilisation
européenne donc tout le monde voit bien
quel est le problème les causes peuvent
être parfois très local mais il y a
quelques raisons qui peu qui qui qui
sont clairement européennes donc je ne
vois pas de de de réouverture possible
en revanche je je suis assez persuadé
que ça va occuper l'espace du position
politique des différents partis qui font
des
propositions voilà ça permettra au moins
que la question
agricole que tout le monde prend un bras
le corp depuis quelques jours retrouve
voilà c'est important puis que
finalement c'est c'est le premier budget
européen donc on parle de 27 à 28 % du
budget européen c'est quand même pas si
neutre que ça et et puis si ça peut
permettre une forme d'intérêt sur cette
élection ça ne sera que que que mieux
donc je vois pas ça en tous les cas pour
la
réouverture avant le avant le l'échéance
électorale sur l'Ukraine bon là pour le
coup on peut pas attendre le mois de
juin voilà donc nous on a demandé très
clairement que des choses puissent être
faites à Bruxelles je comprends que ça
frémi là avec la présence des des chefs
d'État et de gouvernement quels seront
les niveaux des annonces je ne le sais
pas mais évidemment les clausveres sont
sont nécessaires mais là encore je
trouve que le niveau de réac est quand
même affligeant enfin ça fait des mois
qu'on explique qu'il y a un problème
voilà sur l'Ukraine et puis tout d'un
coup quand les choses s'embrasent en
quelques jours on va trouver des
solutions moi ça me questionne vraiment
sur la compréhension la compréhension
des des grands enjeux je je voilà je
vous le dis donc l'Ukraine on espère que
là dans la semaine on aura des annonces
sur la possibilité de mettre en place
des clauses de sauvegarde après est-ce
que se mettront en place tout de suite
dans quelques semaines voilà on a je
l'ai dit on veut absolument ça concerne
les volailles les œufs euh le sucre et
les céréales et dans les céréales il y a
euh évidemment le maïs et le et le blé
et ensuite on veut veiller à ce que
l'année de référence soit 2022 et non
pas 2023 puisque l'année dernière comme
je vous l'ai indiqué et voilà donc vous
voyez il y a des petits points de détail
qui n'en sont pas vraiment sur
euh sur votre question madame la
sénatrice vous parliez des
productions de votre région oui sur
l'endive on connaît sujet le sujet c'est
qu'il y a un déserban qui s'appelle le
bonalan qui est appelé à être retiré du
marché et qui n'a pas qui n'offre pas de
de solution dans un moment où cette
production pour pouvoir se développer a
aussi besoin d'énergie parce que en fait
le forçage des IF se faitc de l'énergie
et donc on a espèce de conjonction du
facteur de j'ai pas les moyens de
protéger ma production et l'énergie a
explosé comme chez la facture de tous
les Français et du coup je me retrouve
en grande difficulté de production y
compris avec la possibilité de voir
disparaître cette production en France
que tout le monde se rassure on
continuera à manger des endives en
France voilà mais ne seront plus de
produits chez nous c'est un problème
voilà et donc on revient à la question
que je disais tout à l'heure sur
qu'est-ce qu'on met en place pour
trouver des réponses techniques qui
permettent de continuer à produire sans
qu'on ait sans qu'on ait finalement
l'arrêt de la production parce que les
gens disent voilà mais je pourrais
prendre ça avec la carotte de créan je
pourrais prendre ça avec tout un tas de
d'éléments donc là on est vraiment on
est vraiment dans
[Musique]
le dans le sujet et vous m'avez posé la
question des conditions d'arrêt alors je
suis très à l'aise parce que en fait
d'abord on va écouter ce qu'à nous dire
le Premier ministre
voilà ensuite on interrogera nous nos
troupes pour savoir est-ce que ça paraît
entendable pas entendable
voilà je l'ai dit il faut bien qu'on
explique qu'il y a différents
timings d'abord il y a des mesures
d'urgence attendu je
dit mais je je l'entends depuis hier il
y a des gens qui disent par exemple nos
collègues bretons nous disent moi j'ai
un problème avec le ratio prairie
pardonnez-moi c'est un peu technique
mais enfin c'est l'idée que y compris
quand vous avez arrêté l'élevage depuis
6 mois on vous dit vous devait
réimplanter des prairies et on nous dit
ça on sort pas tant qu'on l'a pas mais
en même temps moi je suis obligé de leur
dire que ça c'est une décision
européenne et que la France seule ne
peut pas emmener euh cette décision et
que au même titre que les 4 % de jaer
qui questionneent l'obligation jacher
questionne et que on y est depuis 9 mois
on prend que peut-être de manière
dérogatoire il y aura des choses dans le
qui qui pourrai sortir mais voilà donc
il y a des choses françaises qu'on peut
avoir tout de suite sur la directive IOD
au niveau européen qui est aussi très
attendu en viande blanche je pense au
pou pondeux je pense à la dinde je pense
au port voilà c'est une décision qu'on
pousse beaucoup mais il y a eu un
trilogue à Bruxelles donc on est en
train de regarder si on peut
éventuellement il y a des possibilités
de de de de de de rouvrir avec des
amendements si euh euh le le le le le
vote n'a pas lieu tout de suite alors en
plus je le dis IED prévoit que avant
l'entrée en application de la directive
en 2028 il y a une clause de voyur en
2026 moi j'en découvre tous les jours
hein mais euh euh voilà donc je je je je
ces conditions elles seront dééfinies
puis ensuite il y aura le troisème temps
je vous l'ai dit hein mesures d'urgence
mesures européennes puis a les mesures
législatives et là je me tourne vers
vous c'estàd qu'à un moment ça va vous
passer entre les doigts euh voilà donc
je parle pas des des PPL qui peuvent
être déposés par les différents groupes
parlementaires je parle de ce que va
porter le gouvernement et et proposer
aux deux assemblées dans lequel on va
voir si l'agriculture est au-dessus de
tout alors je je redis ce que ce que
j'ai dit he moi on a pas demandé ça on
veut juste que un moment on prenne la
place qui est la nôtre voilà et que les
les les mots les mots se traduisent dans
les faits qu'est-ce qu'on dit sur
agriculture euh d'intérêt général majeur
voz il y a un moment parce qu'en ce
moment tout le monde nous dit qu'il nous
aime je suis ravi hein mais on va quand
même un moment passer au travaux
pratique voilà est-ce que quand on dit
il nous faut des Ines d'impact dans la
loi ça a du sens est-ce qu'à un moment
on peut dire on a aussi besoin de
veiller à ce que il y ait le droit de
l'environnement et il en a besoin mais
il y a aussi un sujet de souveraineté
alimentaire et et que on ne vienne pas
les entrechoquer en permanence est-ce
qu'on peut trouver un équilibre voilà ce
qu'on demande nous et donc on verra bien
ce que sont les condition j'ai rappelé
les différentes thématiques sur l'eau
par exemple il faudra qu'on lève un
certain nombre de de freins parce que le
stockage de l'eau c'est c'est c'est
nécessaire et qu' aura pas d'agriculture
sans eau voilà donc après il faut faire
attention au milieu enfin aller
expliquer que par exemple dans le Pas de
calis chez vous madame il y a en 2 mois
près de
180 millions de mè cubes d'eau qui ont
été rejeté à la mer par des pompes et
que par ailleurs pour irriguer toute la
région pas juste le département toute la
région il en faudrait moitié moins c'est
quand même une question de bon sens
alors je dis pas qu'il faut le faire
n'importe comment je dis pas qu'il faut
le faire partout je dis pas qu'il faut
le faire de manière déraisonnable je dis
juste que se poser la question relève du
bon sens
voilà écoutez je je peux vous
dire mais je vous ai parlé de la région
monsieur jade voilà vous êtes de l'INE
oui bon donc vous c'est pas un d' non
pas encore bon donc stocker de l'eau
dans cette région dans cette région des
haut France c'est un sujet y compris
parce qu'on on y produit beaucoup de
cultures spécialisées beaucoup de
cultures spécialisé et que donc on aura
besoin d'eau et que même cette région
des Haut- defance peut demain avoir des
sujets de sécheresse majeur donc voilà
il faut qu'on le regarde voilà quant au
pold puisque vous y faisiez référence
monsieur le sénateur nous par exemple on
s'interroge pourquoi quand c'est un pold
d'air en Hollande ils ont un tout petit
peu d'expérience sur les sujets de PO d'
il y a une obligation légale de curer
les faussées et si vous ne le faites pas
vous êtes amendable et en France si vous
le faites vous êtes amendable peut-être
qu'à un moment peut-être qu'à un moment
on peut avoir un peu d'intelligence
collective sur ce sujet voilà donc les
conditions de de sortie sont à à
regarder sur les questions de de
monsieur le sénateur jado
euh bon vous dites il y a un paquet mais
il y a pas de loi enfin vous connaissez
un peu le sujet et moi aussi on a un
tout petit peu parlé de de NRL on a tout
petit peu parlé de chour ces différentes
directives européennes discuté pendant
des mois donc je veux dire aujourd'hui
chour on sait ce qu'il en est devenu
mais NRL est toujours là on sait pas
comment ça va sortir encore voilà donc
ça explique pas
lajourd'huord non je dis que quand
même ce que ça contient à questionner le
monde agricole voilà je vous ai expliqué
que c'est la crise d' aujourd'hui c'éta
de la sentation je redis je n'explique
pas que c'est un
facteur conjoncturel qui explique
aujourd'hui je dis que structurellement
l'accumumation crée l'incompréhension et
que ce que je vois remonter aujourd'hui
parfois des gens qui me demandent de
revenir sur des choses qui ont 15 ans
voilà donc je je dis pas du tout que
c'est ça je dis que simplement pour
essayer de redonner parce que moi ce qui
m'intéresse dans le moment dans lequel
on est c'est de redonner une vision
c'est qu'on soit capable de se projeter
à 6 mois à 5 ans à 10 ans c'est ça qui
attend le monde agricole là là on est
planté là on est planté bon mais il y un
moment le rôle qui est le nôtre c'est
essayer de de redonner une vision c'est
de dire l'agriculture a encore un sens
en Europe l'agriculture elle peut encore
faire vivre dignement des gens elle a du
sens dans le métier elle nourrit les
gens je je je note avec intérêt que que
que les gens sont plutôt sensibles à ce
qui se passe en ce moment et plutôt
positivement sensible je suis pas sûr
que ça dure longtemps s'ils soit ils
sont embêtés tous les soirs rentrant
chez eux mais en tous les cas on entend
ça donc ça fait partie du package
d'ailleurs depuis le début j'explique
qu' y a des sujets français donc c'est
pas ça c'est pas l'Europe moi je fais
pas partie de ceux qui revoi à Bruxelles
systématiquement parce que c'est facile
de viser Bruxelles je dis que il y a une
part de responsabilité à Bruxelles
ed c'est un irritant qui est sur la
table parce que encore une fois
l'éleveur breton il comprend pas il
comprend pas voilà donc il comprend pas
que on lui explique que il a un élevage
industriel qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que on l'empêche pas de
produire ça veut dire qu'on va lu
demander de remplir plus de
papierers
c'est c'est voilà en port par exemple
c'est c'est c'est 120 truit alors que la
moyenne nationale française est autour
de 170 180 mais 12 truit aujourd'hui si
vous remplissez des papiers toute la
journée les gens disent mais c'est
cfcaen voilà c'est ça que je veux dire
et après moi je vous parle du ressenti
parce que les gens n'ont pas conscience
de de de ce qui se passe donc je ne dis
pas que c'est que ça mais je dis que ça
peut participer vous me posez la
question de l'exception agricole mais
comme vous je la découvre depuis hier
donc je je je m'intéresse beaucoup parce
que je je connaissais l'exception
culturelle donc du coup on a commencé à
travailler pour regarder s'il pouvait y
avoir des parallèles mais au moment où
je vous parle je ne sais pas voilà mais
je je manquerai pas d'interroger le
Premier ministre mais puisque j'ai
compris qu'il venait cet après-midi
faire sa déclaration de politique
générale dans cette maison je vous
remercie si vous lui posez la question
de l'éclairage de ce que c'est que
l'exception
agricole très bien bon ben
écoutezexer dans en tous les cas voilà
mais moi je je en tous les cas qu'on
regarde l'agriculture avec intérêt me va
bien vous savez les agriculteurs les
mots les formules les trucs machin
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire en dur voyez
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
dans la vraie vie des gens je crois que
c'est ça qui nous intéresse
euh un petit mot sur l'agneau
néozélandais ou
bon et vous avez dit tout l'intérêt
d'abord je voudrais donner le chiffre on
importe aujourd'hui 60 % de notre viande
auovine 60 %
donc ça veut dire un que nous on peut
progresser on peut en produire plus mais
je me réchouis monsieur jade que du coup
vous m'diez sur le loup ça va m'aider
beaucoup parce que dans rég bah dans les
Alpes dans les dans les Alpes 55
départements venez dans les Alpes mari
nous aider non non non non si si non
attendez attendez si si si non mais non
non pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout
je vais vous répondre c'est je dis je
dis que la filière ovine aujourd'hui est
traumatisée par la question du loup mais
posez-leur la question si vous en avez
produit posez-leur la question ne venez
pas me voir
et non non mais attendez je je je je
jouis au bille je jouis au bille je je
je
redis demandeer au producteurs au vin
vous les connaissez bien allez les voir
demander quel est leur préoccupation par
rapport à la prédation je dis le loup
mais je pourrais parler d'autres choses
ce que je pas é parlons structurel
aujourd'hui nous on sait bien qu'on va
pas passer de 60 % d'importation à
autoproduction donc déjà ce qu'on
voudrait c'est qu'on nous a la place de
pouvoir en produire plus avec des
conductions de production je vous ai
parlé de la laine mais de tous les
héritant donc premier élément il faut
qu'on nous aide à produire voilà et ce
qui avait été fait dans la pack avec des
aides auovin et tout ça allit dans le
bon sens parce que c'était pas juste des
aides couplées à la production c'était
aussi des aides à la structuration de la
filière et c'est une des filières qui
sait le mieux structurer je le lis parce
que du coup parfois les politiques
publiques quand même amènent à des gains
de productivité sur l'importation donc
première réponse il faut qu'on en fasse
plus vous avez compris et donc tout ce
qui est de nature à voilà mais dire
qu'on sera autosuffisant demain donc il
faudra qu'on continue à importer ce
qu'on nous a dit c'est que c'était des
accords des accords de libre échange
nouvelle formule enfin voilà je sais pas
ce que ça veut dire close miroir
nouvelle formule mais non mais
voilà et on nous dit que quand on fait
la l'Analyse de Cycle de Vie
deimportation on est avec des choses
plus verdueuses moi ça m'interroge
beaucoup et puis je voudrais aussi qu'on
parle du sujet de bien-être animal parce
que il y a aussi des sujets majeurs de
de de cette nature bon ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est comment on garde des
gens qui veulent continuer à faire de la
production au vin c'est ça qui
m'intéresse en France donc je je ne suis
pas en train de vous dire que de toute
façon faudra pas qu'on en importe on en
aura besoin ce qu'on comprend pas c'est
le cumule parce que là Nouvelle Zélande
mais vous auriez aussi parler de
l'Australie dans lequel il y a une Louge
supplémentaire qui est pas signée à ce
stade mais qu'on attend c'est le signal
qui est important monsieur le sénateur
le signal c'est de dire on compte sur la
production et puis après si on en a pas
il faut en importer acceptons de
regarder ce qui nous gêne en ce moment
c'est que ça détruit de la valeur et de
la capacité de production et donc quand
je parlais des irritants et que
volontairement je je disais que la
prédation je je vous prie d'entendre que
le sujet de la prédation c'est un sujet
qui préoccupe les éleveurs au vin il y
en a pas partout dans toute la France et
des endroits où ça se passe bien donc on
a de la place pour le marché il s'en
consomme et on peut aller plus loin donc
faisons cet effort ensemble et et
veillons à ce que on n pas de sujet vous
me parliez
décapitalisation du chetel bovin c'est
une vraie préoccupation c'est une vraie
préoccupation d'abord ça fait partie de
ceux qui ont aujourd'hui les revenus les
plus faibles en moyenne voilà avec des
sujets de alors je distingue le lait de
la viande bovine c'est c'est pas
exactement les mêmes problématiques en
lait je vous en ai parlé en lait y
compris parfois dans des élevages de
taille conséquente je pense à la
Bretagne il y a desj en carête de
guerlass qui disent moi j'en ai assez
parfois voilà est-ce que les quotas
seraient de nature à à remettre laamique
je pense qu'on est au-delà de ça vous
savez les cotas quand ils ont été mis
dans le lait en 1984 personne n'en
voulait et puis quand on les a retiré en
2014 tout le monde voulait les
garder non non mais ok tout le monde
nétait pas contre les non non non à
l'époque en globalement les gens en 84
étaient quand même pas super favorable
au cota
voilà oui oui ce que je vousou expliquer
c'est c'est l'état
d'esprit va pas parler de 84 mais voilà
quand en 2014 on a retiré les quotas
tout le monde a
craint libéralisme le marché
voilà je crois pas qu'on reviendra au
cota pour vous dire et dans le moment
dans lequel on est c'est même plus le
sujet dans le moment dans lequel on est
c'est l'attractivité du métier c'est
qu'est-ce qui fait que quelqu'un se dit
dans le moment auquel je suis je vais
accepter vous reprenez une exploitation
laitière il faut engager des capitaux
vous avez le cheptel le hangar un peu de
matériel quelques terres autour voilà
donc vous immobilisez du capital de
manière importante avec une rentabilité
qui est faible vous travaillez
sensiblement plus que la durée légale du
travail il y en a d'autres hein quand
vous êtes commerçant artisan vous sa
travailler aussi donc je veille toujours
à pas donner le sentiment qu'il y a que
les agriculteurs qui travaillent il y a
beaucoup d'autres gens qui travaillent
mais enfin faisons le constat que nous
on travaille et et enfin vous avez des
revenus qui sont
euh alors il peut y avoir des bonnes
années en l'IT et il y en a eu et tant
mieux et elles sont méritées mais enfin
voilà et donc la fatigue elle est morale
aussi en l'IT voyez les gens qui disent
voilà je je donc comme les prix de la
viande étaient assez élevés l'année
dernière on a eu des la grosse
décapitalisation après il y a encore des
gens qui y croire et moi c'est c'est
c'est pour cela que qu'on qu' qu'on est
là c'est comment on fait pour continuer
à garder une production laitière vous
savez les grands acteurs si demain il
faut qu'ils aillent acheter du lait
ailleurs ils le feront mais on a aussi
des laitteries ancrées dans les
territoires qui fonctionnent et qui sont
d'ailleurs souvent celles qui payent le
lait le plus le le le le plus élevé et
puis on a aussi vous l'avez dit des
signes de qualité quand on est dans la
filière comptée aujourd'hui avec voilà
on oui mais ça veut dire je fais écho
parce que là on est sur un marché où il
y a une autorégulation c'est-à-dire que
c'est pas des quotas mais mais mais à
l'intérieur à l'intérieur de
l'organisation on s'est mis des règles
j'aurais pu prendre l'exemple du
champagne aussi qui se met des règles
d'une année sur l'autre pour pouvoir
stocker des jus et et voilà donc je
trouve que quand même sans rentrer dans
l'encadrement du marché parce que ça je
pense que c'est plus d'actualité l'idée
en tous les cas qu'on puisse réguler
parce queil y a pas en agriculture de
solution en dehors d'une forme de
régulation c'est important et je le dis
aussi parce que tout le monde dit la
FNSEA le libéralisme et tout c'est pas
vrai il faut regarder la réalité de ce
qu'on produit donc en agriculture le
libéralisme c'est mortifère mais
l'encadrement de tout et des prix c'est
pas crédible non plus donc il faut
trouver les vois et moyens et ce qui a
été fait dans unble de filières le
compter en est une il y en a d'autres
c'est intéressant et et les filières je
pense par exemple à certaines laitteries
qui travaillent des produits spécifiques
y compris lu la eu acheter voilà avec
des prix il y a des gens qui payent le
lait très bien en ce moment avec des
écarts de prix qui peuvent être
supérieurs à 50 € les 1000 lit d'une
laitterie à l'autre ça ça interroge le
producteur laitier voilà donc nous on a
besoin encore une fois d'y croire saz
l'élevage là il regarde ce qui se passe
il regarde ce qui se passe où on est
capable de donner une dynamique ù on
n'est pas capable et moi je voudrais
finir par là si vous m autorisez madame
la Présidente encore une question ben il
y non Jean-Claude Sébastien Anne Anne et
Daniel gréier allez on y vaite alors
c'est sûr alors Anne rapidement
Jean-Claude oui merci déjà monsieur le
Président bon bien que c'est nemarnais
je pense quand même être suffisamment
objectif pour vous réaffirmer notre
soutien ici au Sénat moi je voulais
juste qu'on se penche de minutes sur les
les perspectives de diversification
auxqueles on recours certaines
entreprises agricoles enfin certains
exploitants pour joindre les debouts
tout simplement votre regard là-dessous
là-dessus pardon savoir si euh il y a
bon ben des des des diversifications qui
qui qui qui sont majeur éventuellement
des verrous que l'on pourrait faire
sauter euh et voilà que qu'on ait votre
bilan tout simplement merci Jean-Claude
oui rapidement c'est pas question c'est
une remarque mais sur faisons attention
à la démagogie quand on parle de
surposition surtout quand on parle de de
produits phyau la France est quand même
un des pays qui autorise le plus de
molécules si on si on se compare à la
Pologne à l'Allemagne euh je nai plus en
tête mais
et non mais Jeon je je vous Sébastien
Sébastien sur la viticulture peut-être
encore une fois oh non plus politique un
peu de viticulture mais non moi je
passais la fin de la semaine là sur les
les manifestations avec mes confrères
vigoron et euh je suis inquiet je suis
inquiet parce que les les dérapages et
instrumentalisation politique faite par
notamment le l'extrême droite qui a
tendance un peu à tiser à tiser les
flammes n on a trois députés qui se sont
pris en photo une pancarte qui faisait
référence à une affaire qui concerne
Sandrine Rousseau là va faire la soupe
donc vous voyez un petit peu le
niveau le niveau de de de ces mecsl et
je crois qu'il faut pas se se voiler la
face face à ces ces provocations gr
grotesque euh ben il faut pas s'étonner
que surviennent ensuite des des
dérapages assez graves dans vos
manifestations puisque nous avons eu un
attentat il y a 15 jours de l'adralal a
explosé le matin à Carcassonne et puis
lors de la manifest tion de vendredi
dernier c'est la la MSA qui a été
carrément détruite par le mouvement
viticole et agricole qui était justement
monté par par votre organisation
professionnelle et qui absolument pas
cautionné évidemment par les leaders
syndicaux donc moi je je suis
particulièrement inquiet par rapport à
ça et je voulais avoir votre avis parce
que j'ai j'ai l'impression que ce jour
au-delà de tout ce que l'on a dit le la
problématique fondamentale que que
connaît le le secteur agricole
aujourd'hui il y a des pistes réflexion
mais derrière ça je pense que se joue un
rattrap politique par rapport aux
élections européennes bientôt et surtout
aux élections consulaires en fin d'année
j'ai j'ai j'ai vraiment l'impression que
que que l'extrême droite et la
coordination rural joue ce match dans ce
temps politique
aujourd'hui je pense que la la
difficulté du monde agricole telle
qu'elle est tel que nous la connaissons
aujourd'hui cette désespérance mérite
mieux que des calculs politiques en vue
de de ces élections là donc je je
voulais vraiment voir votre avis sur ces
encombrants soutiens infiltrés dans vos
manifestations organisées par la FN se
et puis enfin bon ce matin il y eu des
annonces au niveau viticol Mo je suis
assez satisfait de du résultat puisque
nous nous demandions des fond un fond
d'urgence millions d'euros il sera 80
millions d'euros des primes à
l'arrachage est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est ce sera suffisant pour régler la
crise viticol qui touche l'intégralité
des régions françaises aujourd'hui merci
voilà monsieur le Président pour
clôturer votre longue et au combien
intéressante intervention alors pour
répondre à à la sénatrice chenarch donc
sur diversification verrou d'abord il y
a beaucoup beaucoup d'exploitations
agricooles beaucoup d'agriculteurs qui
ont déjà fait de la diversification
parce que tout le monde cherche des
solutions et c'est pas nouveau donc il y
a des gens qui vont faire de
l'agrotourisme il y a des gens qui vont
faire de la transformation à la ferme il
y a des gens qui vont faire tout un tas
de de de de produits voilà il a il y a
quelque chose qui monte assez fort c'est
la production d'énergie hein de plus en
plus de gens qui mettent des
photovoltaïques sur les bâtiments
d'élevage qui s'intéressent au sujet de
la méthanisation qui se r sur les sujets
demain de d'agrivoltaïsme voilà avec
tous les les tensions que ça peut
exercer sur la pression du foncier sur
sur tout un tas d'autres sujets mais en
tous les cas la question de la
production d'énergie interroge beaucoup
et puis voilà les les la diversification
c'est pas nouveau et est une solution et
et va continuer à l'être et puis je vous
ai parlé des services pour enfin des
paiements pour services environnementaux
ça aussi c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
continu à pousser parce que on pense que
c'est une source de de revenu sur les
surtranspositions monsieur le sénateur
je vous en donne une comme ça vous
verrez que ah donc voilà je je moi en
fait ça ça m'intéresse pas tellement de
de de chercher je dis il y a des
surtranspositions j'ai parlé des néoniqu
par exemple tout à l'heure qui qui qui
qui qui est flagrante bah écoutez quand
c'est autorisé dans un pays et pas
autorisé en France et que l'Europe
France pas demandé la bonne dérogation
vous savez c'est pas uneposition c'est
que la France a demandé des semen ené
alors que l'Allemagne demand des
périsations non mais non non mais c'est
c'est bon je je je non non mais je
partage pas votre point de vue monsieur
le sénateur mais c'est pas très grave
voilà enfin à l'arrivée ce que constate
l'agriculteur français c'est qu'il l'a
pas avec son voisin là et que l'Europe
le permet voilà bon oui oui bon mais
encore une fois moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est pas de chercher voilà c'est de
dire parce que je vois bien ce qui est
en train de monter comme débat on
voudrait opposer la production et
l'environnement ça ne nous intéresse pas
ça nous intéresse pas je je dis pas que
c'est votre propos mais c'est quand même
ce qui vole en ce moment donc je je je
précise puisque je suis puisque je suis
devant des parlementaires voilà en gros
en expliquant que il y a ceux qui jouent
la production l'argent le grand capital
et puis de l'autre côté ceux qui
protègent l'environnement moi je je dis
simplement si demain il y a plus
d'agriculture française ou moins
d'agriculture française c'est plus
d'importation est-ce qu'on aura gagné la
réponse c'est non comment on fait demain
sur les leviers de décarbonation
d'amélioration si on n pas la prod vous
savez pour qu'un sol et capacité de
décarbonation faut qu'il produise et qui
stock voilà donc ça il faut on en parle
ensuite moi je je je je me bats pour
qu'on essaie de de pas opposer la
question de la haie étant un sujet voilà
donc tout ce qui est de nature à
faciliter la ligne entre les décisions
parce qu'il faut des décisions il faut
un cadre réglementaire je dis pas que il
faut rien et ce qui se passe dans nos
fermes nous va bien et donc il y a des
surjets sur transposition
environnementaux il y a pas que ça il y
en a d'autres il y a pas que
l'environnement non plus il peut y avoir
aussi des sujets de surtransposition
dans d'autres domaines donc il faut
qu'on les regarde il faut qu'on bien sûr
c'est pour ça
je focalise pas sur l'environnement
voyez je dis il faut qu'on les regarde
qu'on les prenne et puis qu'ensuite on
dise voilà et puis peut-êtreussi parfois
la surtransposition nous a aidé voyez
j'essaie de rester voilà pas beaucoup
d'exemples peut-être que ça peut exister
donc moi mon sujet c'est qu'on reprenne
et qu'on regarde si ça facilite ou pas
et qu'on aille au bout et ça c'est très
attendu aujourd'hui vous voyez bien sur
enfin la question de des
inquiétudes écez moi je encore une fois
je je je je
porte je porte ce qui est la ligne
politique de notre syndicat je je sais
pas ce que fait le Front national je je
fais pas de commenta politique moi je je
me contente de de rester dans mon dans
mon domaine qui
est le syndicat professionnel agricole
que je représente avec des compétiteurs
euh les autres font ce qu'ils veulent
vous voyez ce que je veux dire et les
gens se définiront moi je l'ai dit
publiquement 1 le temps des élections au
champ d'agriculture viendra c'est dans
un an je suis pas sûr d'abord je suis
persuadé que la plupart des agriculteurs
qui sont aujourd'hui sur les barrages
l'ignore donc ça n'est pas la question
du moment voilà que certains les en tête
j'ai pas de doute mais les agriculteurs
là ce qu'ils veulent c'est des réponses
concrètes maintenant tout de suite dont
ils ont le sentiment que ça va changer
leur vie demain dans leur ferme c'est ça
qu'ils attendent donc vous parliez de de
l'enveloppe viticole elle est supérieure
à ce qu' avait été demandé donc première
chose pe dire il y a un signe qui est
donné vous l'avez dit aussi il y a
beaucoup de choses qui ont déjà été
faites pour la viticulture le sujet de
la viticulture c'est un sujet très
conjoncturel avec un malêre que que tout
le monde a ressenti c'est d'essayer
d'apporter des solutions de court terme
la vraie le vrai sujet de la
viéticulture mais ces gens-là le savent
très bien pour les avoir rencontrés à
plusieurs reprises c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
fait du marché comment on adresse la
question du climat est-ce qu'on on
essaie de trouver une solution pour la
question de l'eau quand elle est
possible euh comment on fait de la
segmentation parce que il y a des
régions qui ont fait beaucoup de progrès
mais qui vait arriver des vins d'entrée
de gamme qu'on francise dans des
conditions qui sont illégales voilà bon
donc c'est c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on
essaie de discuter donc à court terme
c'est comment on sort les gens de l'eau
parce que il y en a qui sont en train de
se noyer et c'est essentiel de le faire
ensuite à moyen terme c'est tous les
sujets autour de l'arrachage temporaire
définitif je suis pas compétent c'est
pas à moi qui appartient dans dans des
décider mais dans tous les cas qu'on
aille loin et puis ensuite qu'on discute
de la vision qu'est-ce qu'on fait de la
vitirculture française qui est aussi une
viticulture très différente euh voilà
parce que les problématiques des uns
sont pas les problématiques des autres
les choix de segments qui ont été faits
par les uns et les autres ne sont pas
les mêmes et puis Comand on essaie
d'harmoniser ça dans un contexte
mondialisé où régulièrement les V et
spiritueux français font l'objet de de
de contraintes quand Airbus et Boeing se
frotte c'est la viticulture française
qui trinque quand Bruno Leem dit y a 15
jours les véhicules et électrique
chinois on va pas financer c'est un
panel sur le sur le cognac voyez donc
tout ça concours à des
interrogation peut-être pour finir si
vous m'autorisez madame le Président je
voudrais dire ce que ce qu'on ce qu'on
veut porter d'abord à court terme faire
que on est un signe très clair que le
monde agricole est écouté ensuite je le
dis parce qu'on sait qu'il y a des
mesures d'urgence qui vont arriver mais
que d'autres prendront un peu plus de
temps on peut pas jouer avec ce
mouvement on ne ne peut pas jouer avec
ce mouvement et il est pas question et
il est pas question que dans quelques
semaines on se rende compte que la
fièvre tombant le problème sera réglé il
n'en sera rien et donc on a besoin
absolument que les réponses en
profondeur soi apporté les réponses en
profondeur soi apporté alors nous on va
travailler pour essayer de trouver les
conditions qui satisferont les gens qui
sont aujourd'hui sur le terrain et qui
les aid à comprendre mais ça c'est pas
de la responsabilité de la FNSA c'est de
la responsabilité du gouvernement et
donc faut bien que chacun porte ses
responsabilités donc la fnsoa elle elle
dit ça va ou ça va pas mais elle
commande pas voilà elle décide pas à la
place du gouvernement bon ensuite il y
aura une fin je sais pas quand elle sera
mais il y aura une fin il y aura le
temps du travail sur les sujets de
simplification parce que ça ça peut pas
être juste des mots donc il faut que ça
se traduise dans les cours de ferme
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire simplifier
demain il y a eu des annonces de faê les
annonces elles vont dans le bon sens
mais les annonces les agriculteurs ça
fait longtemps que ils disent bon
maintenant ça fait
quoi faudra probablement une dizaine ou
une quinzaine de jours on a le salon de
l'agriculture qui commence dans 3
semaines qui est un moment de communion
avec les Français qui est un moment de
de de bienveillance d'accueil
d'explication il faut que ça le reste
enfin il faut que tout le monde soit
conscient aussi que si d'ici 3 semaines
il y a pas il y a pas ce qu'on attend ça
va pas être la visite de santé on vient
faire les photos au cul des vaches je je
préfère le dire aussi très clairement et
donc vous voyez bien que la position de
la FNSEA c'est en responsabilité de se
battre pour trouver des solutions parce
qu'on peut dire aussi ça va pas ça va
pas faut tout péter très bien mais il y
a un moment c'est quoi après voilà donc
nous on met des propositions sur la
table elle satisfont elles satisfont pas
en tous les cas nous on fait notre
travail de proposition d'un syndicat on
travaille main dans la main avec les
jeunes agriculteurs parce que on
considère aussi que c'est important que
les plus jeunes etent aussi leur mots à
dire la manière dont on construit
l'avenir parce que je vous ai parlé
d'avenir voilà on dit aussi que
l'agriculture c'est c'est c'est aussi un
métier qui garde du sens qui garde de la
noblesse qui a des sujets aujourd'hui de
revenus de prix on a parlé des galimes
on a parlé de la structuration on a
parlé des importation mais il faut
absolument que ce qui s'est passé là
serve à reconstruire une forme de une
forme d'élan et je l'ai dit en France
mais à Bruxelles et donc la question de
la campagne de la place de l'agriculture
dans la campagne le mois de juin sera
central et je je j'ai la faiblesse de
penser pas seulement en France mais dans
de nombreux États européens et que pour
ce qui nous concerne en tous les cas sur
la question du Green Deal on va
s'employer parce que il faut donner une
ligne claire il faudra probablement
rouvrir la PAC parce que quand on
parle de du ratio prairie quand on parle
des 4 % de non production qui sont
encore dérogatoire au moment où on parle
voilà il faudra quand même qu'on dise
les choses et je le dis parce que j'ai
entendu ou lu qu'on dit ils veulent pas
aujourd'hui il y a déjà 2,1 % de jcher
en France donc il y a pas rien pas rien
c'est faux de le penser voilà mais mais
on dit juste les régions sont pas les
mêmes et il faut qu'on adapte parce que
territorialiser c'est aussi mieux faire
comprendre les politiques et on peut pas
dire de Bruxelles jusque dans mon
territoire il y a pas de typicité donc
il faut qu'on fasse attention et je dis
ça parce que ça veut pas dire qu'on peut
pas avoir une vision commune mais qu'il
faut aussi l'adapter à ce que c'est ce
qui'est la réalité des des territoires
on est dans un moment
difficile je le dis aussi devant les
gens qui sont ici assumer la
responsabilité avec les élus qui
m'entourent de ce syndicat professionnel
c'est aussi prendre ses responsabilités
voilà c'est ce qu'on a fait je pense
qu'on l'a fait avec avec vraiment le le
recul nos gens nous entendent toute la
journée dire ce que sont n nos élus nos
nos no nos nos adhérents mais même des
nonadhérant tous les agriculteurs nous
entendent avoir des propos clairs après
il y a des gens qui portent autre chose
et bien très bien moi je vous aurez noté
que à aucun moment je n'ai fait des
commentaires voilà donc je n'oppose pas
les agriculteurs entre eux je ne l'ai
jamais fait je comprends que la fnso en
ce moment espèce de défouloir c'est pas
grave la ligne est connue que nos
concurrents portent leur vision moi je
je je vous le dis je connais des
agriculteurs qui sont dans d'autres
syndicats je n'oppose pas les
agriculteurs entre eux j'ai du respect
pour tous les pour tous les agriculteurs
mais nous on a dit clairement ce qu'on
portait maintenant c'est au gouvernement
qu'il apparti VI d'apporter les réponses
et puis on commencera après je voulais
vous remercier de votre écue mais c'est
nous qui vous remercions vraiment très
sincèrement parce que vous nous avez
consacré plus de 2 heur d'échange et de
débat dans le moment que vous avez
rappelé ou combien compliqué qui vous
mobilise je dirais jour et nuit donc
merci merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation merci d'avoir répondu d'une
façon aussi claire